في جاهز وصلنا وهذه حقيقه وليست كلام انه
عميل يتصل يشتكي لانه المزاج ما وصل مع
المشروب
وجي تعويض ما تعتقد انه هذا يعني تاثير
مباشره على حصتكم الثاني يبدا الاول من
يقول الثاني هذا الارقام اللي نعرفه
انت تشوف انك الاول اليوم من وين جبتها
اليوم
اذا عندك اذا عندك ارقام عندك احصائيات
قلها يعني انا ضد لما يجي واحد يقول لازم
سعود القضاء كامل مستحيل تقدر الطرح كيف
كانت
افضل
واجمل
واسوى واصعب
[موسيقى]
يلا حيهم ضيفنا اليوم محمد البكر الشريك
المؤسس والرئيس التنفيذي التجاري لشركه
جاهز طبعا شركه جاهز اتوقع كلام نعرفها
وكلنا نعرف تطبيق التوصيل للمعروف الخاص
فيهم لكن الصوره الكامله للشركه فيها اكثر
من كذا بكثير لها السبب اليوم ما راح اضيع
وقت كثير في قصه جاهز من تاسست
كثير قبل كذا صراحه ولا ودي نكررها فبدخل
مباشره في موضوع علاقه تطبيق جاهز مع
المتاجر من ناحيه النسبه كيف تتحدد تكاليف
الاعلام مع التطبيق شكاوى المطاعم اللي
تكون عنها سواء على نسبه على التعويضات
اللي تحملونها شكاوي الناس الاسعار وغيرها
من الامور في الموضوع هذا ثم ننتقل بعدها
نسولف عن تجاربهم في الجانب التسويقي مثل
اشتراك برايم اللي سوى التوصيل المجاني
رعايتهم النادي الهلال تاسيسهم لتطبيق بلو
بالشراكه مع النادي حملات الكاش باك
لاعاده يسوونها بالشراكه مع البنوك شلون
عاد يسوونها ما يتحمل التكاليف تنبغطي
جانب الشركات التابعه لشركه جاهز من ضمنها
شركه مطابخ السحابيه وشركه التوصيل الخاصه
في ومنصه بك للتوصيل للمتاجر نتكلم بعد عن
الاستثمارات ومستحوذاتهم في مختلف الشركات
وليش طولت محاوله استحواذهم على شركه
على شركه
وبنختم في نقاش عنه المنافسين والسوق
وتجربتهم في الطرح والتعليقات اللي جتهم
على انخفاض ارباح الشركه وانخفاض سعر
السهم وغيرها من الامور المتعلقه في هذا
الموضوع حلقه دسمه جدا ومليانه معلومات
غالبا اول مره تسمعها اترككم الان مع
الحلقه
حياك الله ابو عبد الله يا هلا سعيد جدا
صراحه باستضافتك نحاول ننسق اللقاء تعرف
مدى اعجابي فيك الله يعطيك المسيرتك
بالعكس الساعات وحياك باي وقت ما بيضيع
وقت لا في البدايه بس
ولا في الكلام عن قصه جاهز ما شاء الله
تكلمت عنها عده مرات قبل كذا بدخل بالزبده
على طول علاقتكم مع المتاجر ودي نتكلم
عنها بتفاصيل اكثر طبعا هو موضوع جدل يصير
دائما بين الناس على النسبه على طريقه
التعامل على المرتجع على كل الامور اللي
تصير اول مشاكل
ناخذ حبه حبه اول شيء النسبه اللي اعرفه
صح يعني اذا غلطان متوسط النسبه عندكم
تقريبا 12% من جميع المتاجر المطاعم مقايي
ايا كانت وايش اللي يحدد النسبه بالضبط
لانه في مطاعم تاخذ اقل في مطاعم او
المتاجر تاخذ اقل ومتاجر تاخذ اكثر وايش
اللي يحدد النسبه لا طبعا جاهز تقريبا
متساويه فقط وقت الدخول يعني الناس
القدامى معنا لهم نسبه كانت 12 وسط الان
الجدد 15 بس ما في والله انه والله مطعم
كبير مطعم صغير متجر كبير متجر صغير
الا حاله واحده فقط في مجموعه متاجر
المطاعم تابعه
هذا اسر منتجه تابعين تسعه اشهر وكان في
تعاون بيننا وبين سته اعشاب ندعمهم فكنا
نعطيهم نسبه 6% كانت المطاعم ثمانيه
بالميه وصارت الباقي نفس الشيء تلاقي
ماكدونالدز تلاقي بوفيه في شارع الصفرا
ببريده نفس الرقم معقوله ما يجي يقول لك
انا والله قاعد اضيف الجاهز كلهم
مثلا لانك لو سويت فرق بالنسب صعبت
المنافسه عليهم بعد اليوم اذا مطعم اي
مطعم بيه واحد اقوى من الثاني واعطيت
الاقوى عشره بالميه والثاني عشرين بالمئه
دويت هذا بزياده وبديت تضعف هذاك خلك نوع
من النوع ما وجد وصلت قبل كذا مع اي مطعم
من مطعم الكبيره يجون اسمعوا يا جماعه
لازم تكلفوني واجد انا قاعد اجيب لكم
طلبات بالحجم اني بعلامه تجاريه معروفه يا
تنزلونها لي 11 عشره ولا بوقف ما وصلت
الحاله هذه يوصل كلام يوصل نقاش يوصل يعني
بعض المطالبات يوصل بعض الضغط لكن ما وصلت
انه والله عطوني اطلع لا ما جاتنا من
المطعم بعدين هي ترى ترى عمليه شركيه يعني
اليوم انا ما اقول نسبه النسبه ما اتاوى
النسبه اليوم زي الاشجار انت فاتح مبنى عن
طريق الملك فهد مبنى كبير
وتاجر العشر مطاعم او عشر متاجر وعشر
محلات ذهب هل تحط ايجار هذا غير هذا غالبا
الايجار هو على قيمه ابنائك انت وتكلفه
مبلاك انت مع نسبه ربحك فاني اسمع تطبيقات
ثانيه يكون في تفاوت بين السياسات طبعا كل
تطبيق بالنسبه لنا جاهز لا احنا نسبه
ثابته الا زي ما قلت لك في مجموعه
الجدد اللي جوانا بعد سنتين وبعد ثلاث
سنوات من بدايتنا سنوات من بدايتنا قلنا
لهم والله لا يعني معلش اعذرونا هذولاك
اقدم ومعنا من اول والنسبه شويه يعني ما
هي كفيتنا بالحين فرفعناها 15 احنا
شفنافسكم على الاقل اللي اسمعوا قد تكون
المعلومه غير دقيقه بس اسمع من مطاعم انه
هنقرستيشن
وفي حالات قد تصل الى اكثر من كذا فهل
معناته هذا الحين قاعد يشق الطريق لكم
بحيث انكم تبدون ترفعون نسبه هذي او
اختلاف في استراتيجيتكم لا طبعا هي شغلتين
منافسكم هذه برجع لها لكن بالنسبه للنسب
يعني اوكي انت تاجر ودك تاخذ مئه بالمئه
من الربح لك تقدر صحيح
مو صحيح لانك انت اليوم انا ماخذ نسبه
اليوم انا اخذها من التاجر هو التاجر اللي
جالس يبيع اذا ما يربح ما راح يستمر معي
وحاخره بعدين هخسر السوق فانا باخذ نسبه
تريحني وتكفيني وتكسبني ولا تضر التاجر
على الاقل
ليش تاخد 125% نسبه وش اللي يبرر النسبه
هذه انا عارف الجواب بسوي تجاوب للمستمع
طيب هذه كنا بديناها من البدايه ويمكن
النكت انه اول ما بدينا كانت تطلع لنا
اشاعات انه جاهز تاخذ نسب قليله فقط لما
تستحمت السوق ارتفع وتسلخ اسمعوها كثير من
المطاعم الحمد لله كبرنا وصلنا كبار
وطلعنا برا المملكه وصرنا
ولا صرخناهم ولا طلعنا عنها
النظرياتنا فيها اذا ما يكسب التاجر يشتغل
معي انا ما راح اكسب عنه
القيمه اللي تضيفها للتاجر لا هي ليش ماخذ
نسبه وهذا شغلي انا انا وش البزنس حقي
البسس مد الحقي اني انا جالس اليوم
قناه تسويق للمطاعم وتوصيل للاكل حقه تمام
في مجهود في شيء اعمله من وين يجيني الربح
ولا نسبه من المطاعم النسبه ترى على فكره
لما تتكلم على
باقي دول العالم
35% توصل 45% بدول الخليج اقل نسبه 25%
احنا هنا يمكن قلتها يوم من الايام قلت
المطاعم المفروض كل المطاعم يحطون تمثال
جاهز في كل فرع من فروعه لانه احنا جاهز
هي اللي حافظت على نسب منخفضه المطاعم من
ديوان ولا زالت الى درجه انه بعض
التطبيقات الاخرى بدات ترجع بالنسبه تنزل
نزول ما استمرت بارتفاع لانه في موجود
منافس قوي مثل جاهز ونسبته اقل هذا هو
البسس مدن حقي بس بالاخير كم اخذ
المطعم كله لا بد اخذ اللي يربحني ويكفيني
ويخليني اقوى واخليه يتطور وخليني اسوق
لكن برضو صاحب المهنه الاصلي التاجر هو
صاحب البزنس الاصلي وليس انا وسيط اذا ما
يربح ما راح يستمر معناته انا ما راح
يستمر فانت اخذ نسبه باختصار للتسويق
ولتوصيل هذول اكبر اللي يحتاجها فعليا
المطعم عشان يوصل للزبائن بس ليش نسبه
مفتوحه يعني ما هي مثلا باخذ 15% الى 50
ريال مثلا 15% الى 100 ريال وش اللي خلوش
العوامل تقول لا انا احتاجه تكون مفتوحه
متى ما كبر الطلب تكبر النسبه معه
هذا كله ممكن يناقش هي بالاخير انا اقدم
خدمه لك
زين هالخدمه هذه علشان اقدر استمر بالخدمه
ابغى مقابلها مبلغ مالي عشان اقدر اربح
واقدر اتوسع واقدر اسوق واقدر اكمل شغلي
كامل تمام شلون تجي هذه طريقه نسبه في بعض
التطبيقات الجديده جت وقالت انا ماخذ نسبه
اخذ على العميل اخذ مدري وشو يعني
اليوم انا بقدم لك خدمه انا باخذ منك مبلغ
عشان اقدر استمر واقدر اربح من نفس الوقت
حلو هالمبلغ هذا اذا وصل زي ما قلت لك
حصه كبيره من ربحك انت كتاجر بديت تتضايق
تقول ما ابغى نفس الشيء نرجع العماطم على
طريق الملك فهد فاتحه عماره فهد ماجر اذا
والله اجارك هذا يبي يصير يمثل 50% من دخل
صاحب المتجر
حيطلع منك عبد الله روح مره ثانيه بطريقه
منك فهد فهو يبي ياخذ يبي يعني ما عنده
مانع يدفع لك قيمه هالايجار هالمبنى له
لخدمه قد ماله بس بشرط تكون معقوله نسبه
وتناسب من مجمل ارباحك فانترا النسبه
وصلوا الان التجارة الى فهم لقيمتها يقول
انا فاهم فعليا انه هذه القيمه قاعده
اخذها من الجهاز فهذه مستحقه
استمرار الخدمه هذي كمالها حنا اليوم
رفعنا ممكن اذا 13% وشرحنا التطبيقات
وكلهم تقريبا للمطاعم وكلهم تقريبا
اقتنعوا
اننا ليش زدنا واحد بالميه كان شرحي لهم
حرفيا وبيقولوا لك الان انه اليوم احنا
كشركه مطالبين بزياده ارباح عندنا
مستثمرين ومستثمرين يبغون وين توسع
ارباحنا من وين تجي مداخيلنا فكان يضغطون
علينا مستثمرين يقول لك ليش انتم جاهز اقل
نسبه بالعالم
فلو نقبل ضغطهم ممكن نرتفع لنسب توافق او
تساوي نسب باقي التطبيقات لكن نرجع على
على ثقافتنا اللي احنا نقولها او او
اعتقادنا انه النسبه يجب ان تكون دائما
مرضيه دائما تارك مساحه ربحيه كبيره
للمطاعم عشان كذا جينا بزين الكنبرمايز او
بيننا وبينه مستثمرين والمطاعم قلنا خل
نزيد واحد بالميه نرضي المستثمرين رفعناها
شوي ولكن ما ناثر كثير على المطاعم كانوا
مستثمرين يطلبوا لنا نرتفع اكثر من هذا
بكثير والمطاعم ودهم ينزل فجينا على
هالمعادله لارضى تقريبا عرضت الجهتين
المستثمرين والمطاعم تمام هذه في الوضع
الطبيعي انت عندك 13% تاخذه من المطعم
مقابل تسويق وتوصيل بس في الواقع في مطاعم
خاصه المطاعم الغير معروفه يعني المطاعم
تحاول
نقول في السنه الاولى ولا السنه الثانيه
لها في تكاليف اضافيه عليها في تكاليف انه
لازم يطلع نفسه في الواجهه جاهز ما راح
يجيه التسويق بشكل تلقائي في تكاليف ممكن
انضمام لجهاز برايم لانه هذه بندخل في في
فقره خاصه فيه اللي بيصير يدفع اكثر على
الطلبات لانه يدخل مع يحتاج يدخل توصيل
مجاني واذا ما دخل توصيل مجاني بيصير شكله
هو الاغلى ما بين المطاعم الثانيه من
ناحيه التكلفه الطلب ففي تكاليف اضافيه
فوق النسبه ما تشوف ان هذه قاعد طبعا لازم
نكون يعني منطقيين مع جميع
اول شيء عندك صاحب بزنس تكلمنا الان على
مطاعم انت صح من مطعم عندك تكاليف وعندك
اسعار
وتبيع تربح تشتغل بدون تسويق حتخسر
المطاعم للتسويق هتخسر لكن تجي تشتغل وتحط
ميزانيه تسويقيه كبيره اكبر من حجم
مبيعاتك بكثير حتخسر كمان فوازنها اليوم
مثلا لو جينا على التسويق المفروض تسوق
داخل التطبيق وخارج التطبيق المفروض تسوق
صح لكن خلك متوازن انا اجي دائما كثير من
المطاعم اقول له والله لا تجي تبي تسوق
مثلا لما تتكلم على شهر كامل
ايام متقطعه نعرف يعني مره ومره بحيث انك
تكون موجود تسوق تصرف تسويقيا لكن لا تصرف
اكثر من اللازم بعض اصحاب المطاعم يعني
اكبر مطعم
تسويق شهر كامل وهو اقوى مطعم بالمملكه
يعني
تسويقيا
بس مع ذلك ما يجي يقول والله انا بسوق طول
السنه عندهم ميزانيه ضخمه
ولا تلاقيه موجود بالاوت دور طول السنه
لازم تحسبها يعني تخيل وهذه ويمكن تسال
اصحاب مطاعم وحيقولون لكن نجلس مع اصحاب
مطاعم يبغى يصرف عندنا نقول له لا
ليش لا تصرف ما تحتاج لا تخسر
يعني بعض المطاعم يجوك وانا ابغى احجز سنه
كامله لا لا تحجز سنه كامله غلط بس
المفروض
اي تسويت طال عمرك له حد معين وينتهي
مفعوله ما تيجي تصرف ميزانيه مفتوحه عشان
تقول باخذ الدنيا بكسر الدنيا بعض اصحاب
بالذات شباب الاعمال الشباب في المطاعم
تكلم في الشباب
استولي على السوق ابغى اطلع منافسيني
كلام غير صحيح كلام غير صحيح تذكر بحياتك
كامله كم منافس طلع منافس من السوق
انت الحين اسالك من يوم وعيس على الدنيا
وعرفت شيء اسمه تجاره لليوم
كم منافس شفتوا انه طلع منافس بسبب تسوي
ما راح تلقى ما راح تلقى وين لقيت واحد
اثنين وتلاقي الاسباب ما هو المنافس اسباب
داخليه بالشركه نفسها تعبت بس مو منافس
طلعها ما عرفت تواكب ايه يعني دخلنا على
ماركات ارجع ما ابغى اقول ماركات ارجع مع
ذاكره مشروبات ارجع ذاكره بالسيارات ارجع
الذاكره باي شيء
موجودين ما يجي واحد اصرف اكثر بطلع
الثاني انت كتاجر احرص على شغلتين احرص
انك تتوسع وتربح بنفس الوقت اذا وقفت
التسويق اتكلم اذا وقفت التسويق
حتزود ارباحك بالقطعه لكن حتقل مبيعاتك
بالجمله فحتقل ارباحك
الجماليه والعكس صحيح لا والله ضربت
بالتسويق وصرفت ميزانيات كبيره حتكبر
مبيعاتك
مشكله في كفاءه التسويق عند التجر يعني مو
ما بيقول كفاءه لكن
ثقافات وهي خبرات تتراكم ويتعلمون الناس
كلنا نتعلم لكن هي بشكل عام اتكلم من اي
بيزنس
بالدين لا افراط ولا تفريط صح صحيح نفس
الشيء يجي واحد انا ما ابغى اسوي اي مجهود
تسويقي
ما راح ماسك كذا ما راح يكبر والثاني
فاتحها بحري الميزانيه التسويق مفتوح
[موسيقى]
راح تلاقي اكسبلور بالطريقه هذه باي تطبيق
بالعالم
فاكسبلور هي صفحه خارج صفحه المطاعم فما
يعني العميل اللي مستعجل بيطلب يدخل
الصفحه انه طعمها امير رايق روح الاكسبلور
حتشوف ترندي ريسترا ترند
تشوف انواع كثيره تشوف بعض الامور
الثقافيه شوف بعض احصائيات الخاصه فيك
تشوف وش الاهم
التغييرات بالسوق وخلالها حيكون في
اعلانات برضو وش المشكله اللي تبغون
تحلونها
ما في مشكله نبي نزيد نخليها التطبيق اكثر
عمق نبي تصير اقرب من عملائنا احنا يوم من
الايام دخلنا جيم
بالتطبيق اليوم داخلين اكسبلور نبي نصير
اكثر قرب من عملائنا واكثر عمق يعني
ونتطور احنا احنا من يوم بدينا الحمد لله
من يوم بدينا يعني فكره التوزيع عن طريق
طرف ثالث من بداها بالمنطقه جاهز
وكانوا كثير رهنونا راح تفشر والحمد لله
الجميع الحق وانا فيها اليوم جالسين نطول
شغلات كثير هذه واحده منها
يوصل المطاعم يخلي المطاعم هنا يتوصل هذا
المده اللي كان موجود اصلا بس هذا انت ما
حليت مشكله على فكره
ترجع المطاعم كانت تجربه سيئه لا غير
تجربه سيئه لكن وش كان الوضع قبل
الوضع قبل في مطاعم معينه عندها اسطول
توزيع وباقي المطاعم اغلبها ما عندها
المطاعم المقتدره اللي عنده توزيع فكانت
توزع عن طريق التلفون او عن طريق يدقون
عليهم ياخذون الطلب كذا جهه التطبيقات
اللي نزلت بكالوقت صارت تختم هذولا انه
بدال ما يجيك تلفون حيجيك الطلب من خلال
التطبيق انا بعطيك التقنيه لازم لاداره
اني اجيب لك الطلب تقنيه وارسله لك وتكمل
طيب ما حليت المشكله من ناحيتين
السبعين بالمئه من المطاعم ما عندهم
اسطوره توزيع ما استفادوا هذا واحد اثنين
ما كانت العمليه متكامله ما كانت يعني
للجميع اطراف التطبيق لم ياخذ الطلب ما
يتابع الطلب لما يروح المندوب لما يوصل
للعميل وياخذ طلب ويرسل للمطعم
بطريقتك التقليديه
فالحل كان من نفع مع من نفع مع الشركات
والمطاعم اللي ما عندها اساطير
اسلوبنا صار لهم حل انه والله يقدر يوزع
بدون ما يتكلف باسطول كبير وبدات العمليه
وبعدين لحقونا كل التطبيقات اول سنه
ودائما هذا اي واحد جديده يضحكون عليه
يقولون ايش عنده هذا عنده مده ما راح ينجح
شويه ويمشي
بعد مرور سنه كل التطبيقات اكتشفت انه هذا
القرار الصح وهذا الطريقه الصح فقلدوها
كلها
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
انطلق بادخارك الادخار يخلصك من الديون
يمنحك الحريه الماليه لبدء مشروعك بنفسك
حمل تطبيق سيركليز
حلوه انا برجع على تكاليف حق المطعم من
ضمنها بدايه موضوع التسويق اكسبلور ما
اتوقع الدفع المطعم اكثر دفع اذا دخل
المستخدم على الاكسبلور ممكن نستغني بعض
الاعلانات اللي حسينا انها تضايق العملاء
والمطاعم يبغونها يعني مثلا لما تفتح
التطبيق الحين يطلع لك
مفيد لنا في داخل مادي مفيد للمطعم يعلن
المطعم فيها مزعج للعميل الان البابا
حنستغني عنه قريبا ويكون الاعلان داخل
اكسبلور موجود اعلانك ومستمر ما هو باب
يجلس الفتره معينه فما يكون مزعج للعميل
العميل اللي فاضي بروح يتصفح يروح يشوفه
العميل اللي مستعجل ولا يبغى اي شيء يطلب
ويمشي اكسبلور لازم المطاعم تختار انه
تشارك معكم ولا انتم اللي تديروا
الاعلانات المدفوعه
هذه المطاعم المحتوى اللي موجود لا
المحتوى بعضها يجي المشاركه من المطاعم
ونطلب منهم مشاركه يعني اختياريه لهم
وبعضهم من عندنا وبعضهم من
الذكاء الصناعي عندنا يعني الان الان لما
اديت لعندنا فالان مثلا انت حيصير اكسبلور
عندك يختلف عن الواحد ثاني انت مثلا حتجيك
شغلات اذا انك والله من محبين البرجر
وكذا
اللي تشابه لاختيارك يعني والله السيستم
يعرف انك والله
المطاعم معينه فلما يجي برجر جديد مثلا
عنده وجبه انت تحبها ممكن يطلعها لك وترى
هذه جديده لما يجي ترند بمجال معين ببعض
المكلات حيطلع لك فهذه كلها تكون طالعه من
الديث الموجوده عندنا تمام فهذا حتى يمكن
يساعد التسويق المطاعم برضو بشكل افضل
فعندك النسبه قلنا حق المطعم عنده
الاعلانات
يدفع كم تقريبا على الطلب مبلغ ثابت شارك
في قيمه التوصيل يصير هو يدفع جزء نتشارك
احنا وياه فيها مبلغ ثابت
وفي برضه التعويض العملاء يكون على حساب
المحلات صح لا التعويض ترى هذا يجي كلمات
كثير وتجي بتويتر ساعات ويجي بعضهم ويكتب
بتويتر انه والله جاهز بالاسم يقولها
جالسه تعوض على حساب المطاعم
مش صحيح بالشكل هذا
متى حسابك انا
واحد جاهز من يوم بدات كانت مؤمنه انه يجب
ان نختم العميل بطريقه لا يتوقعها
وفعلا اعتقد ولازم تعتقد واقولها وقلت
اكثر من مره جاهز عملت فرق بخدمه العملاء
في المملكه
يعني يمكن في مثال قلت اكثر من مره قالت
طبعا
يعني عشان ما اغفل غيرها جالس سوت بس برضو
في تطور حكومي حكوميه والوزارات تشتغل بس
وقتها تتكلم على الكاستمر لو صار عندك
مشكله مكينه السياره مشتريها يمكن تتردد
تروح تشتكي ولا لا انك ما تدري عونك ولا
لا
الوكاله
في جاهز وصلنا وهذه حقيقه وليست كلام انه
عميل يتصل يشتكي لانه المزاز ما وصل مع
المشروب
وجيت تعويض
ففكره جاهز اني بعوض العملاء هذا
واحد وبصير كريم لما تعوض العملاء حتكون
بين نارين
طيب في ناس وبكل مكان موجودين في ناس
يستغلون هالكرم الزايد فاذا انك انت
تتساهل بالتعويض فحيجون الناس تستغلونه صح
يستغلون وهاي تزعج المطاعم واحنا معهم نصح
لكن كيف اضبط هالمعادله اني والله اعوض
المستحق بشكل كبير وسريع وسهل وبنفس الوقت
ما اثر او ما اخلي مساحه كبيره خل اقول
للمستغلين مستغلينها التعويضات حلو فيجي
هنا برضو الذكاء الصناعي انه اليوم انت
طلبت
تعويض على طول قدام اللي بيقابلك مسؤول
خدمه العملاء عندنا شايف ملفك على طول
والله طلباتك كلها كويسه هنا في تعويض انت
صادق خلاص مشيك ولا حقق ولا شيء
انت والله اخر طلبات كلها طالب فيها تعويض
فعلا تفهم عليك
توصل ويمكن ما تبغى للناس توصل انه في
تدرج
عميل واضح انه كويس على طول الممثله
يختموا على طول شويه متعب يحول السوبر
فايزر شويه كثير طلباته نطلب منه ايميل
لانه ايميل او شيء مصعب العمليه عليه
بعدين نبغى نحقق اكثر فيه حلو وصلنا مرحله
انك والله
يا مشهور عميل غير صادق غير امين معنا
حسابك اخسرك ازيلي هذه المعادله بشكل كامل
نيجي على المطاعم التعويض مو كلهم المطاعم
التعويض احنا جاهز العام الماضي اكثر من
اربعين مليون قيمه المصروف من جاهز على
التعويضات ورقم ما هو ترى لما تسمعوا باي
مكان بالعالم ومشاركه تدفع 40 مليون
تعويضات مبلغ كبير هذا دفعته جاهز من
ميزانيه جاهز
تعويضات على ثلاث شغلات
اذا والله المشكله من المطعم مئه بالمئه
وغالبا تكون مشاكل مطاعم والله
طالب سبعه برجر وصل سته هو مو تعويض
هو تعويض العميل اعطيه حقه لكن المطعم ترى
انت دفعت قيمه اللي ما توصل لك اللي ما
وصلته انت استلمت
100 ريال لعشره برجر
وصلت ثمانيه برجر
معتبرين نسبه للمطاعم 14% 12% لنا 2%
العملاء
فلو جت التعويضات عليك واحد بالمئه تاخذها
تحاسب عنك وش السناره الثاني غالبا هذه
اكثر شيء اثنين والله اذا تاخر الطلب بشكل
كبير لو جبنا مثال تاخير الطلب اذا تاخر
الطلب بشكل كبير لها ثلاث حالات
اذا الطلب تاخر بالمطعم عن الوقت المتفق
لتجهيز الاكله هذه اللي هو كم على حسب
تغسل في المطاعم بس تقريبا لافرج عشرين
دقيقه لان بعد المطاعم تحتاج وقت اكثر
فاذا قلنا عشرين دقيقه وانت سلمت الاكل
بعد نص ساعه
ووصل للعميل واشتكى
متسبب المطعم فهو يتحمل حاله ثانيه انت
سلمت المطعم بالوقت
والمندوب راح لف وصل طلب ثاني تعرف القصه
هذي كلها وصل العميل متاخر العميل حيتحمل
التعويض الحاله الثالثه جاهز المندوب
المندوب نفس المندوب نفسه اذا المندوب
تاخر بالتوصيل استلم بالوقت المناسب وتاخر
لما وصلوا للعميل بدون سبب منطقي ما كانت
زحمه ولا اشاره مقفله ولا شيء لا هو وراح
وصل طلب ثاني ولا اي شيء المندوب يتحمل في
الحاله الثالثه انه والله وصل الطلب وجاهز
تاخرت باسناد الطلب الى مندوب كان في
المناديب
فما وصل المندوب ما اسند الطلب الى مندوب
الا بعد وقت وتاخر تسليم الطلب هذا جاهز
تتحمل التعويض لها تفاصيل كثيره
بعض المطاعم هل مشكله التواصل مشكله
توقعات بعض المطاعم معهم حق بس انا لما
اشرح لهم يعرفونه
مطعم يجي
يلاقي كيس معينه انه في عميل
اشتكى والعميل غير صادق واخذ تعويض
فيجون يسوون تست مثلا بعض المطاعم يجون
يسوونها
لا يسوونها
من مطعمة
عشره برجر مثلا زين ويرسل طلب عشره
ويشتكي انت جاهز يوصلني سبعه
ونعوضه
فيقول هو هذا كاذب شنو عوضتوه على حسابي
منطقيا صح كلامه بس لما تقيسها انا دائما
اقول لهم الشغله هذي طيب خلنا نتفق هل
نبغى نخدم العمله الصادقين او لا
اذا قلنا نبغى نخدم العمله الصادقين
واعتقد المتفقين كلنا نبغى نخدم الصادقين
فعلشان اتاكد انه هذه النسبه البسيطه من
العملاء غير الصادقين وغير امناء عشان
يعني ما يخدعوني يفتحون المطعم لازم
استثمر مبالغ اكثر من قيمه التعويضات
عشرين مره لازم اول شيء احط بكل مطعم
كاميرا
الكاشير ويعبي هذه ومربوطه برقم الطلب
وحتى موجود عنده مطعم على حساب المطعم
خدمه عملاء الدرجة
واحد عندي ازود عدد خدمه العملاء عندي خمس
مرات اضاعفهم فحط ارفع لكم على المطاعم
عشان اغطي كوستي عشان اكتشف هذولا مو
بعملي ابدا ابدا احنا شو نسوي فكرتنا وهذه
اختراعنا
نقول افترض الجميع صادق
انت اليوم لو تجربها وتطلب تقول ناقص
بيجيك
لكن تقدر يعني مره ويمكن تخدعني مرتين بس
ما تقدر تقنعني ثلاث مرات
والخامسه حقفل حسابك واوديك لتطبيق اخر
وفي جميع الاحوال المحكومه في الاثنين
بالمئه هذي وكل دائما نقيس لا اثنين
بالمئه هي زين مقياس
دائما نقيسها من حالات النادره انك تلقى
التعويضات صارت واذا لقيناها ودائما يقول
المطاعم حتلاقي اذا عندهم فروع كثيره
هتلاقي فرعين ثلاثه عندهم مشاكل فيها يعني
عدم انضباط فهتلاقي التعويضات قليله قليله
قليله مرتفعه هناك
فهنا طور بعملياتك عشان تنقص حلو فانت
عندك
كنا نسبح حقت الطلبات في برايم في
التعويضات اذا كان الخطا من المطعم هالشي
ادى المطاعم كثير انها ترفع اسعارها يقول
انا قاعد يطير علي النسبه هذه بحق او بدون
حق لا لا الاسعار يعني اول شيء ترى ترى
قصه باي شيء كبير
واغلب المطاعم اسعارها ثابته
ورفع سعر ما لها علاقه بهذه لها علاقات
بامور كثيره بعضهم ما يقدر يرفع بشكل عام
فيرفع جزئيه بس ما هي ترى قاعده عامه
القاعده العامه 90% من المطاعم هي اسعارها
هي نفسها يعني بعض الاسئله تسالني اياها
الان
نتائج تغريدات بتويتر السبعه وثمانيه
اشخاص
لما تتكلم لما تشوف تغريداتها سته وسبع
اذا عند الوقت اقولها لك
تحس وكانه هالعمليه وكان المطاعم خسرانه
وكان العملاء تعبانين وكان الدنيا سوداء
خذلتني
الفرق اللي بحياتك بيصير ترى في جوده حياه
كبيره صارت في تغير كبير صار حتى بالستايل
حياتنا حتى لو تكون شباب باستراحه اذا
تذكر اذا كنت باستراحه يوم من الايام الهم
لما مين يجيب العشاء
وتخرب الليله وتخرب الجلسه تلعبون بلوه
تخرب البلوت وقف لما يرجعون لما يجي اللي
راح يوصله الاكل ويجيبه تغير السائل كثير
تخيل انه والله بنات في بيت ياسين بالبيت
متجمعين
ويبغون أكل
المطاعم من بعض المطاعم التطبيقات
المجرمين في ناس يقولونها بتويتر السبعه
هذولا وبعضهم وبعضهم في السبع
تخيل انك صاحب مطعم
وما في تطبيقات توصيل
وعندك وحده من حالتين يا عندك سطول يا ما
عندك
اذا ما عندك اسطول كم واحد بيجي ياخذ منك
كم تبي تبيع بعد الساعه عشره بالليل اليوم
اغلب المطاعم تشتغل 24 ساعه كم نسبه بيعك
وا خدمه يستخدمون
حلو هذه كيف كانت أقول لك عليها الحين اذا
عندك اسطول كم الكوست اللي بيكلفك كم
التعب
ونسبه العماله ومشاكل العماله وصيانه
السيارات
ترتاحت من الموال هذا كله
بس طبعا دائما الناس بعض الاصوات العاليه
تخلي الصوره كانه ما هي واضحه التطبيقات
على مستوى العالم عامله فرق كبير بالنسبه
ارجع لسؤالك
اساطير المطاعم
بالصدفه
احنا ما عندنا مانع بالعكس احنا نبغى
نحتاج مندوبين اكثر واكثر واكثر
واكتشفنا بالصدفه عنده مساطيل ويتوقعون
انه نرفض لا نتعامل معاهم
تشتغل عن طريقه
بتغريده واحد بتويتر كتب انه كتب تغريده
على مطاعم زي العاده كذا واحد قال له طيب
ليش ما يستخدمون سواقينهم مع التطبيقات
رد عليه التطبيقات ترفض
[موسيقى]
عاده بس انه يقدر يسترجع جزء من قيمه
التوصيل اذا كان يستخدم مناديبه ممكن يطلع
الفائده اكبر معقوله
لانه الان في شركات تشتغل هي شركات
شغلها من التوصيل شركه توصيل شركات
التوصيل فهو الان صار يشتغل شركه توصيل
معه شغله كمطعم فلما يطلع له 13 ريال على
الطلب يمكن الطلب نفسه حقه ما يطلع ما
يفرق عنده مندوب ولا عشره ولا عشرين بس
طبعا يفرق شغله واحده اني اسمح لك
توصل طلباتك هذا لاي مطعم
اسمح لك توصل طلبات الغير اذا صار عندك
الشروط الكافيه من نهايه النقل ان سامحت
لك انك تشتغل توصيل لازم تاخذ لك يعني
تاخذ موافق بشكل مفصل بس في زي ما جاوبتني
عليها والسعر من يتحكم فيها
سعر الوجبه نقول النسبه الصغيره والمطاعم
مثل ما تقول رفعت اسعارها ما نقدر احنا ما
نتغيره والسعر يجي من مطعم احنا
ما لنا علاقه بالسعر طبعا في بعض اسهل
تقول ولا ترفع ولا تقول له حط السعر اللي
تبيه احنا ما نبغى يرفع بس ما نقدر نجبره
لكن في بعض الناس يجي يقول لك والله
التطبيقات ترفع السعر وتاخذ فائده مضاعفه
مدري شلون يتوقعون انه يتغير السعر وعلى
مصلحتنا مو صحيح احنا السير يوضع من
المطعم هو اللي نقبله
ما العلاقه بها موضوع بس هي نسبه قليله
الرفع الاسعار ماي بس دائما الصوت العالي
يجي
للسبعه الله يهديه
بس اغلب السبعه فكره حبايب تواصل معهم انا
والله صدق واعرفهم واتواصل معهم يعني
يحبون طيب
للعشرين بالمئه مطاعم كثير داخلين معهم
بعشرين بالمئه
بالخليج نفس سياستنا بالخليج احنا ناخذ
15% بالبحرين مثلا اقرب منافس لنا اقل
نسبه عنده 22% واحنا 15 نقدر نروح عشرين
هنا بالسعوديه نقدر نروح ما حد يمنعنا
منافسنا اعلى منه ومنافسين اعلى منه بكثير
تطبيقات اقل من جاهز كعدد وكذا وحجم
ونسبكم اعلى
الفكره انه احنا نرى
انه النسبه يجب ان تكون عادله
للطرفين مفيده لنا ولا هي مخسره للمطاعم
حيث المطاعم يقدر يكبر ويتوسع ويزود هم
اللي بحاول اعصره لا
لانه كل ما قلت النسبه كلمه قدر اسعار
كانت منطقيه المطعم وبدي يحط الوجبات اكثر
المطاعم يعني سبيس انه يكبر ويسوق
يزود لكن والله تخيل اشتغل معك وانا مخلي
لك واحد بالمئه
حتكون طول عمرك تقول متى اتركه
انا اتذكر في قصه يعني زمان وانا صغير
شفت خبر استغربت
انه انه دول اوبك
حاطه نطاق سعريه كذا ما يزيد عن كذا
فكذا افكر بوقتها بعقليه البسيطه طيب
عشان ما نخسر فما لكن ما يزود عن كذا ليش
للبترول ليش
ما كنت اقدر اتصور افهمها اتذكر 45 دولار
زي كذا طيب ليش ما يروح خمسين ستين سبعين
ميه ليش كل ما يبغى يزيد
فهمتها بعدين بعد ما كبرت فنفس الشيء انا
انا ما ابغى ما ابغى ازيد ربحي بشكل بحيث
اني اوصله مطعم انه والله
انا خسران مع التطبيق خلوي اللي خير اخر
يحتاج وزنها بحيث ان المطعم بيستمر معك زي
الطلبات ويستثمر في تسويقه تكمل خدمه
الحجز اللي عندكم اللي ضفتوها برضو نفس
النسبه ما في
خدمه توصيل
[موسيقى]
وفعلته خاصيه الاستلام من الفرع تقريبا
قريبا حلو أنا مستعجل واروح استلمه
التوصيل مجاني لا لا قريبا
[موسيقى]
ثمانيه تكتب نشرات بريديه متنوعه ذكيه
وممتعه خليك على الاطلاع التخصص اللي يهمك
والمواضيع اللي تشدك وتساعدك تكتشف
اهتمامات جديده تعرف على نشراتنا عن
الحياه اليوميه والافلام والكتب حتى كوارث
اشتركت اللي يناسبك منها توصلك على بريدك
مباشره نترك لك رابط الاشتراك في الوصف
[موسيقى]
عند الزملاء بعض المرات بعض المدراء اقسام
عندنا شغله ويقول ليش ليش ما تركز على هذه
ابغى هذه تخلص بسرعه ولا كذا جاهز ترى مع
انه الان من يوم بدينا مبتسال على تطبيق
التوصيل في جاهز وهو جزء بسيط من شركه
جاهز
فيه خدمات كثيره يعني فما تقدر تنزل كل
شيء اليوم
الطلب خدمه البيك اب حتكون قريبه نازله
حجوزات طلعت
اكسبلور اللي يقول لك الان طلعت خدمه
الوالد المحفظه المحفظه طورناها بشكل كبير
اليوم تقدر تحط فيها فلوس وتحول من محفظتك
لمحافظه ثانيه وتصير فيها شغله
انه والله اليوم واحده من نزاع العملاء
المطاعم يقول انت الان تاخذ تعويض مني
والعميل يروح يطلبني مطعم
فكانوا طالبين والان تبي تصير واعتقد اذا
اذا نشر الحلقه هذه يعني حيكون بعد اكثر
من اسبوع فهتكون صارت اصلا قبل لا تنشر
الحلقه انه خلاص انت خليت التعويض من مطعم
اكس حتستفيد من التعويض هذا في مطعم نفس
الشيء لا الكاش باك اذا كان في كاش باك
منه مطعم نفسه لكن اليوم في شغلات داخل
تطبيق جاهز للجميع كاش باك داخل جاهز هو
داخل جاهز للجميع لكن تعويض عوضك مطعم اكس
التعويض هذا تصرفه فقط في مطعم عوضك جاهز
تصرف في اي مكان في تحويل بين المحافظ
الامور هذه تحتاج تصريح مركزي
المحافظ عادي لانه هي ما هي ما هي كلوزلوب
ما تقدر تكيش
يدخل مبلغ هذا ويصرف فيه جهاز
ثاني خدمه جت خدمه
خدمات مع اتصالات السعوديه
للقطاف خلال الايام شرح تشتغل
قاعده تصب الى الحمد لله تقدر تشحن
بطاقه سوا ولا بطاقات موبايلي عن طريق
الجاهز
كثير كثير من الشغلات الحمد لله اللي بدات
تنزل جميله انا بدخل على مواضيع كثيره لها
علاقه في الامور اللي ذكرتها بس ودي اختم
نقطه النسبه بس معلومه مهمه انه بالنسبه
اللي يذكرها بخصوص سواء هنقرستيشن واي
تطبيق ثاني خلال اللقاء هذا نسبه كمثال
فقط النسب طبعا تختلف في سواء في مرسوله
وغيرها بتكون نسب مختلفه حسب المطعم وحسب
اتفاقياتهم فقط كمثال وليس تثبيتا للنسبه
عشان ما يزعل حدا التطبيقات هذه ودي ادخل
على الجانب التسويقي ابتداء في جهاز برايم
وش اللي دعاكم بدايه جهاز برايم اللي هو
للي ما يعرفونه اشتراك ادفع مبلغ ثابت
شهري واحصل على توصيل مجاني من المطاعم
والمشاركه فاشلخ لكم تبذرون جهاز والله
هذا مو اخترع مو اخترع من عندنا هذه خدمه
ابراهيم موجوده على مستوى العالم يعني
باكثر بالتطبيق فهذه احنا انا قلتها قبل
شوي احنا نختلف شغلات كثيره لكن في شغلات
برضو نقلد فيها فهي موجوده عند كثير من
لان الخدمات خلي اقول على مستوى العالم
فمثلا امازون موجوده
فطبقناها زيها طبعا هذا البارت الاول منها
البارت الثاني حيكون اكبر الان برايم انت
تستفيد فقط من انه توصيل مجاني قريبا وهذه
تستفيد من مزايا ثانيه انه مثلا لما تكون
المدينه زحمه ومقفله الخدمه حيكون انت
مفتوح لك الخدمه لما نكون احنا ساعات
بجائز نصغر مسافات حسب الزحمه حسب تواجده
المندوبين فساعات نصغر لثلاثه كيلو ونكبر
الى 25 كيلو انت ابراهيم حتكون دائما 25
كيلو ففي كذا ميزه
لعملاء برايم حتنزل وش اللي يغير السعر ده
ما والله بديته 95 بعدين خمسه وسبعين
يتغير كل شهر اجدد اكتشف كل اسبوع
اكشف المبلغ مختلف وش اللي يغير في سعر
اكون صادق جرب
بصراحه يمكن ما تصدقني فيها سعر برايم
السعر العادل ما بين 75 الى 95 حلو هو
السعر العادي لابراهيم بداناها وهي خدمه
البرايم خمس وتسعين تكون مفيده
للعميل لان للمطعم انتم كنتم العميل يدفع
مقدما مثلا مقدمه من الخمس الطلبات هي
خدمتها
حتكون مفيده لك 95 حلو انا لما احافظ عليك
طول الشهر حتكون مفيده لي المطعم يدفع
مبلغ اقل
فيكون برضو يجي ميزه انه عمل برايم يجون
اكثر فهي متروسه بهالطريقه وهذه المطعم
قاعد يدفع زياده بس انه يسوق لانه العميل
ابراهيم حياخذ منه ما ياخذ من مطعم ثاني
راح ياخذها مجاني هنا الحين تحيز
لمطاعم برايم اكثر
الان لما تجي وفي ميزه هنا مجاني وفينا
غير مجاني فتفرق معك انا قصدي مثلا
التوصيل مجاني يخلي العميل مثلا ما يطلب
من مطعم يطلب منه عاده بس انه ما هو مشارك
في برايم يروح يدور يعني ما هي بهالطريقه
ميه بالميه بس تزيد نسبه انه بيطلب من
هناك اذا كان خيار العميل نفس الشيء
تقريبا مطعم ايه
هذا بدون سعر بدون توصيل بيروح لهذا لكن
انا والله مشتهي مثلوثه
ما راح احل البرجر بيتزا عشانها بدون
توصيل
تقدر تشارك نسبه المطاعم اللي شارك
نسبه عاليه
[موسيقى]
لكن نسبه عاليه يمكن فوق الثلاثين بالمئه
فهذه الفكره التي تخدم في النموذج هذا حق
الاشتراكات ممكن واحد يشترك معك مثلا
بخمسين ريال ب 60 ريال 90 ريال ولا يوصل
عدد الطلبات اللي افترضتني بيطلبونه
فتتربح منه هذا المده الحقها اصلا الحين
انت لما تدخل تامن على سيارتك وتامن على
نفسك
الفكره هو الاقتصاد التشاركي
امنوا الف واحد زين
200 منهم استخدموا التامين اكثر من قيمه
التامينهم الثمانين باقي ما استخدموا
استخدموا اقل بالاخير المؤمن مستفيد
والمؤمن عليه مستفيد هذه الفكره يعني نفس
الشيء
تخلوا خمسين الف ببراهيم
عشره الاف طلبوا ثلاثين طلب
يعني نظريه مخسريني انه صارت كلها مجانا
30 طلب 5000 اطلبه بحدود العشره فيكون
الباقيين طلبه سبعه ولا ثمانيه
كمثال
عشره ريال بالمجمل انا كسبان كشركه فوقها
تضمن انك
كسبان في مطعم كسبان ما تصور بتكملهم كذا
ممكن بتضيف مزايا اكثر المجاني وتبدا ترفع
هذا الصحيح جاهز دائما جاهز دائما تشتغل
على رفع القيمه رفع الفالي وليس المبلغ
فالحمد لله يعني احترام من يوم بدات جاهز
واسعارها اغلى يعني دائما عند العملاء ان
اغلى من غيرها
يتذكر بدايات جاهز سمعت كلمه استراحه
وقلت للزملاء اتذكر الامير مشعل
والغصاب المنديل
نجحنا
باستراحه جالسين في واحد ما يعرفني فيساله
يتكلمون جاهز وباقي التطبيقات عندهم اسمي
فقالوا واحد قال والله انا
اذا جيعان اطلب من جاهز لنظمه بسرعه
ومضمون وصوله اذا لا ما انا جيعان ادور من
ارخص تطبيق واطلب منه
فصار
الثقه في جاهز هذه الحمد لله اللي موجوده
الى اليوم الى اليوم
اللي يبغى الخدمه الاسرع الافضل حيلاقيها
ارخص ممكن يلقاهم الى اليوم اقول لك ممكن
تلقاها مكان ثاني ما تعتقد انه هذا كانه
يعني تاثير مباشر على حصتكم السوق الثاني
يبدا الاول
الثاني هذا الارقام اللي نعرفه من وين
جبتها انت تشوف انك الاول اليوم من وين
جبتها اليوم
اذا عندك اذا عندك ارقام عندك احصائيات
قلها اذا في احصائيات
موثوقه قلها اما الناس تتكلم كلام كثير
انا ما اقدر اجيب لك شيء موثق مئه بالمئه
بس اللي يعرفوا انه هنقرستيشن هو الاول
وجهزوه الثاني الثالث مرسول وبعدين
التطبيقات الثانيه والله كله ندعي في
تطبيق ما ادري شو اسمه قبل فتره قال عشره
بالميه مدري كم
ما هو معروف اتمنى اشوف واحد طلب منه
بسؤال ما فيه احصائيات كبيره لكن احنا
جاهز دائما عنواننا التطبيق الاول
بالمملكه احنا التطبيق الاول بالمملكه بغض
النظر عن عدد العملاء
اللي ما هي واثقه يعني ما في ارقام موثوقه
رسميه او لها مرجعيه تثق فيها طلع ارقام
احنا التطبيق الاول بالمملكه حلو قبل ما
نعدي نقطه برايم تقدر تطلع هذه المشتركين
ولا
تتغير يعني ما اعرف اليوم
كبير في رقم كبير بعشرات الاعلاف او اكثر
حلو
[موسيقى]
رعايه الهلال
من جهتين جايه
يجيب لك الحدث اللي صار وقتها
والسبب الرئيسي السبب الرئيسي احنا بجهز
احنا كافراد يعني مؤسسين للجهز عندنا
نظره يمكن ما كان يشاركنا فيها الكثير
وذاتها اليوم الجميع يشاركنا فيها انه
الاستثمار الرياضي شيء مهم جدا وان
الرياضه صناعه وليست ماضيه وقت والرياضه
يعني يعتمد عليها بالصناعه بالسياحه بامور
كثيره بالترفيه
يعني
مؤمنين بهالكلام هذا وقته مو كثير زينا
فتلاقي كثير من الشركات لما يدخل يحس انها
مطيعه وقت ولا
مش عارف ليش لما يدخل برعايات لكن مقتنعين
بهالمجالها
وحتى لنا كافراد داخل جاهز في ماضينا قبل
جاهز حتلاقي لنا تاريخ بالرعايات كلنا
فمهتمين بهالمجال الرياضي
سبب الرئيسي كان دخولنا جاهز وقتها دخول
رعايه الهلال وقتها انه صار فيه زي ما
اتكلم في حرب اسعار شرسه جدا بين تطبيقين
موجوده
وصلت الكسر عظم
واحنا خسرانين بالسوق لاننا احنا سعرنا
ثابت
والناس هذولا خصومات توصيل مجاني كاش باك
مدري وشو يعني تلاقي تاخذ توصيل مجاني
وكاشفك 50% وفوقها بوسه وما ادري شلون
بشكل خطير
فبدينا نخسر من حصتنا السوقيه واحنا تونا
بسنتنا الثانيه تقريبا
كان قرار استراتيجي هل ندخل بهالحرب مع
الناس هذولا
وكان يعني
حرب اسعار شرسه جدا يعني كتوصيل ولا كل
شيء اسعار بكل شيء خصهم خمسين بالميه كاش
باك توصيل مجاني
حرب حرب شرسه حتى تفوقين جدا
فكرنا جديا فكرنا حتى ندخل بهالحرب بس
منعنا منها شغلتين واحده انما نؤمن
بهالطريقه هذه طريقه حرب الاسعار طريقه
طلع منافسك وطريقه احرق منافسك لا ذاك
اليوم ولا اليوم
الثانيه اننا حتى لو اقتنعنا ان ندخل
بالحرب فكرنا فيها
ما نقدر يحتاج لك على قوله الاجانب
ديبوكيه تحتاج لك مخبه مليان
لانك حتحرق فلوس واجد ما شاء الله احتاجت
فوق خمسين لا بس وقتها اقل من لو صرفناها
بحرق الحرق كان واجد حرق فلوس كانت الموضه
بين ماني بيرمان يعني
واحنا بهذا التفكير
جتنا زياره من الهلال يعرضون رعايه
فكان هو المنقذ طبعا جت
ايماننا زي ما قلت لك في الرياضه كلنا
هلاليين
وهالاجواء اللي كانت بالحرب والاسعار فجت
مناسبه جدا دخلنا بدون تردد
واعتقد وادعي اننا كنا اذكياء بقوه ولا
زله
كانت الرعايه وهذه برضو قصه بقولها لاول
مره يمكن الرعايه معروضه علينا بالظهر
وبالصدر والله انه احسن من الظهر مو احسن
انا اقولها لك اليوم انا ادعي انها ذكاء
كبير مننا واهايط فيه كل سلفي طالع فيه
واحمر كذا منور اليوم
لكن اليوم لو تركز تلاقي يمكن 90% من صور
لعيبه اللي يطلع من الهلال يطلع شعر جاهز
يعني اليوم
لو تقارنوا بالاعلان الرئيسي يمكن يسوى
اكثر وهذا كان ذكاء من عندنا واذا كان جاء
من الهلال انهم موافقوا على المساحه هذي
كانت فاضيه ما فيها شيء فوافقوا عليها فكم
مدخلي لهم بس بالنسبه لنا اعتقد اننا
خذينا
النقطه الاهم بمبلغ ليس كبير رعايه الهلال
من افيد الايات صراحه
كلامه تجاريه استفدتوا كثير
كبير جدا جدا والدليل ويمكن هذه انا ما
ادري اذا صارت بمكان ما بالعالم ولا لا
لكن احنا هنا بالسعوديه الشركه الوحيده
لتجدد رعايتها قبل لا تنتهي هي جاهزه
ما اتذكر ولا اعرف على حسب معلوماتي في
شركه مددت الرعايه قبل نهايه بسنه احنا
كان المفروض ننتهي نهايه السنه هذه احنا
العام الماضي مددنا ثلاث سنوات من كثر ما
هي مجديه من كثر ما هي مجديه وبرضه خل
ادعي بشغله ثانيه اننا شايفين المستقبل
قايلين المستقبل اللي صاير اليوم فعارفين
انه والله الدوري بصير اقوى منافسات بصير
اقوى الرعيات حتصير اغلى
وجددناها مقترح ولا انتم اللي طرحتوا كلهم
الرعايه لكن هذيك الرعايه اتكلم فبالمكان
كانت مهمه
التجديد كان شيء جديد بالعاده اللاعبين هم
اللي يجددون لهم قبل سنتين والله لاعب
عندك كويسين مدد عقده اربع سنوات
ويزيدوا شويه علشان تضمنوا معك احنا بجاهز
جددنا الرعايه انا لحد علمي الى اليوم ما
اعرف هل في شركه بالعالم ماده الرعايه قبل
تنتهي بسنه
وهذا اعتقد انه ذكاء جاهز بلو
بيجي على هامش رعايتنا للهلال
ما هو مرتبط فيها هو لا مرتبط فيها هو على
الهامش الرعايه انت لما تسوي رعايه
والنادي كبير زي الهلال ولا اي مكان
تحتاجك تفعيل
الناس الشركات يعني
خليني اهيط شوي وازيد بكلمه هاي قلتها
مرتين يعني في شركات ترعه وبس تحط شعاره
وخلاص في شركات ترعه وتحط انشطه وكذا
وتصير كويسه ويسمون عمله كويس احنا جاهز
سوينا الرعايه وسوينا وصار في انجيج مع مع
الجماهير بشكل كبير الحمد لله زودنا عليها
قفزنا من الرعايه للشراكه تجينا اقترحنا
على الهلال طيب ليش ما نسوي تطبيق مشترك
احنا وياكم
وهو يرجع لنفس ثقافتنا بجاهزه لما اقول
نعمل شغله
حتكسبكم كثير حتكسبنا كثير ربحانين نعمل
تطبيق مشترك
تقنيا عندنا انه ها وعندنا اداره الحدث
كامله عندنا انتم عندكم الاسم عندكم
المنتجات
فنطلع بشيء مهم طلعنا بلو طبعا كانت يعني
مفاوضاتنا او نقاشاتنا مع الهلال سموث مره
لانه اتكلم مع ناس يعني فاهمين وعارفين
مجال رياضه وعارفين جدا جدا بشكل اكبر
متخيل فطبع بلو اليوم
بعد اعطيك حصري اليوم
قيمته تسوى اكثر من 500 مليون تقييمات
الاوليه طبعا
الحمد لله يعني صار له قيمه كبيره الملكيه
المشاركه بينكم احنا واحد وخمسين جاهز
هي لازم
صعب تصير خمسين خمسين فلازم في واحد يقول
للمالك
51 من ضمن النقاشات انه ادارات الانديه
تتغير مع الوقت قبل طبعا القفز الجديد
اللي صارت الان
الى مشروع زي كذا احنا جاهز
لو انتهى مشروعنا معه الهلال فقط في بلو
كفانه
كفانه جرية بغض النظر عن اي مكسب اخر
كسبناته
الخبرات موجوده عندكم سواء تطبيق او من
ناحيه التوصيل
فالخبرات موجوده التقنيه موجوده بناء
التقنيه كله داخل داخل
فلو ما نطلع الاب هذه احنا كسبانين معنا
كسبنا شغلات كثيره
ولا تشاركونها ولا انه كنا شركه مستحيل
شركه مستقله تبع شركه مستقله
اسمها بلو يملك فيها الهلال 49% يملك فيها
جاهز مدير يعني حلو طبعا من ضمن واجبات
جاهزنا بناء الهيكل الاداري والاشراف على
ادارتها لحد ما تكون مستقله اداريا تماما
فارجع اقول لك الرعايه احنا لو جينا بس
البلوك الثاني مكسب لو جينا
على
العائد المباشر وغير مباشر من الرعايه
اللي جاهز الحمد لله كسبنا
جيت على العائد المادي
مئه مليون اول خمس سنوات حتكمل سنتين
زياده يتواصل 140 تقريبا اكثر من 140
زائد مكافات فوز وكذا بعض الدعم اللوجستي
من جاهز فمفيده جدا للهلال اطلعوا في شركه
يملكونها ولها قيمه نتوقع ان شاء الله
قيمه حتكون
يعني حتدخل عالم اليونيكورن ان شاء الله
وقريبا واكرم مليار باذن الله باذن الله
فانتم حتى عوائد التذاكر تشاركون فيها في
الشركه هذه ولا احنا نبيع التذاكر حقت
التطبيق
كم عدد الطلبات اللي وصلتها بمناسبه في
بلو ستور حاليا
باليوم ولا بالسنه ولا بالساحل
لا بلو ستور عدد كبير الحمد لله بس
بلوستور في ميزه كبيره جدا الحمد لله
خل اربطه بشغله ثانيه كبيره اليوم لما
نتكلم على الاستثمار الرياضي لما اتكلم
على جلبها اللعيبه من كل دول العالم
ومبالغ ومليارات ويجونك بعض الناس والله
جالسين الحكومه تصرف مليارات على مبالغ
ترى هالمليارات تصرف قطاعات كثيره تزيد
منها السياحه تستفيد امور كثيره تفيد
الصناعه
احنا اليوم في جاهز من خلال بلو جالسين
نستفيد من هالاستثمارات اللعيبه اعطيك رقم
صادم 37 دوله شحنا لها
الهلال من
37 سفر اسماء
السعوديه طبعا
من البرازيل من فنزويلا من كوريا الجنوبيه
من
البوسنه من امريكا من فرنسا من اسبانيا
وعدت لاحظ ترى جالسين سجل اليوم ما بدا
الدوري ما بدا الدوري لسه بس يوم بدت بدو
اللعيبه يجون
وجو مجموعه من لعيبه الهلال اليوم احنا
مدري كم التاريخ سته ولا كم عندها اربع
لعيبه جدا جايين الهلال فقط لانه ما راح
تعرض اليوم الحلقه هذه ان شاء الله لما
تعرض يصير واصلين ثمانيه بس عندك اخبار
يعني ان شاء الله اقول فاليوم
جالسين نبيع شيرتات سواء للهلال بشكل عام
او شركه باسامي اللعيبه هذولا 37 دوله
خارج المملكه طلبوا كميه معتبره يعني
ارقام وكملت زود
عدد الطلبات في بلاي ستور مثلا السنه هذه
ما اقدر اقول لك الرقم بالضبط ما يحضرني
صراحه بس انه جالس يزود الحمد لله بشكل
كبير جدا لكن اقول لك انه استثمار بلو
يعني استثمار من
اروعون النقله التلفزيون الحين برضه
تلفزيوني رعايتنا لول نفس الفكره احنا
احنا لما نقولك مؤمنين بصناعه الرياضه
فيها بشكل كبير اليوم النقل التلفزيوني
طبعا
على الميناء
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا فاليوم انا
لما ارى النقل التلفزيوني حتطلع وفي
متابعه كبيره بدول الخليج انا اليوم جاهز
موجود في البحرين موجود في الكويت
فالاعلاني جالس اصرف عليه في السعوديه في
حيشوفون عمل بالكويت عملائي في البحرين
وان شاء الله قريبا بدول ثانيه خليجيه
فجاس استفيد بشكل كبير الزخم ترى الجالس
يصير بالدوري شكل ما تخيله بس
بشكل كامل
سيكل او مركبه كبيره جدا تسرع توصيلك وصول
اسمك باسرع طريقه ممكنه اكثر من اي شيء
ثاني فمؤمنين بالرياضه بشكل كامل انه اسرع
طريقه لتوصيل اسمك والحمد لله احنا جاهز
ترى من الخمس سنوات في ناس يحسبون لنا
خمسين سنه 60 سنه
صار اقوى من شركات عريقه جدا الحمد لله
برعايه الجهه الاخرى
اننا برضه نعتبر انفسنا شركه وطنيه قريبا
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله حنصير من ضمن
الناشونال
شركات الوطنيه
الابطال المحليين الابطال المحليين هذه
شرف في في يعني قطاع حكومي بصير ودعم
حكومي للشركات اللي مرشحه تصير من
ضمنها فاحنا نعتقد اننا شركه وطنيه
واجب اليوم انا من وين جبت فلوسي كشركه من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه كل شغل جايبه
هنا لما ارجع جزء منها على شكل تسويقي في
دنيا تسويقيه ويساعد في دعم انشطه وحراك
رياضي او اجتماعي او حتى
ثقافي او
معك بالفكره بس ليش
تلاقينا بفرم بنفس الوقت تقريبا ذاك الوقت
مع مزين هذه لها جمهوره هذي
يعني
احنا موجودين بالطائره كنا بالجولف بالسله
بالفورملا في
المزاين في الخيل في اكثر الانشطه منها
اثر ولا لا طبعا اليوم لما ارجع واقول لك
جاهزين الاولى بالمملكه ما جت من فراغ
من عمل كثير تقني عمل كثير بالاوبريشن عمل
كثير بالتسويق جزء من هالتسويق هي
الرعايات بس دائما اقولها للشركات
الدقه القديمه يقول لك لا تضيع فلوسك على
شغلات كذا وكذا
اترك الحنه الشركات السعوديه وشركات وطنيه
واترك حتى الجانب الوطني فيها هالشركات
العالميه الضخمه
هل رغبيه فلوسهم
شوف الفورمله مين يرعاها اعظم الشركات
العالميه صح شوفوا الدوريات العالميه مين
يرعاها شوف اعظم الشركات بالعالم حتلاقيها
رائعه اكثر من نشاط رياضي
يعني اغبياء والجسي ضع فلوسهم يلا صحيح
فهي هذه التسويق الرياضه يمكن وقت زي ما
قلت لك بالمملكه عندنا هنا مو كثير ناس
يتوقعون انه هذه
قاطره مهمه للتسويق استفد منها يعتبرونا
اما والله انك تصير يعني تبغى تدعم نادي
ولا تدعم جهه كدعم تحط فيها فلوس ولا راح
ادور غيرها نزلت الرياضه
صحيح وانا قلت اكثر من مره قلت قلت ابو
بكررها اليوم معك احنا مثل مع الهلال كل
ريال دفعنا
جاءنا عشره وعلى فكره الكلمه هذه قايلها
قبل لا ادخل قبل لا تصير في جاهز
قبل جاهز وانا جاي نفس الكلام بالرياضه كل
ريال تدفعه يرجع لك عشره اليوم مع الحراك
الرياض الكبير والدعم الحكومي
يعني الغير مسبوق على المستوى العالم كل
ريال تدفعوا بالرياضه
جميله
من هالحراك بيفوتوا بيفو يفوتوا القطار
فعلا انا اقولها للشركات بشكل عام
وللمنافسين حتى لنا
اذا ما تدخل هالمجال تراك تفوته ترى ترى
في في طفرات تصير مره بالعقار مره كذا مره
كذا اليوم الطفره موجوده بالرياضه
بالسياحه وبالترفيه بشكل كبير جدا اذا انك
شركه تبغى تستفيد لازم تمشي مع المجال
وهي تقول والله مضيعت فلوس راجع حساباتك
جميله انا ودي اختي بالجانب التسويقي في
نوع من الحملات التسويقيه اللي دايما
تسوونها سواء مع البنوك او مع التطبيقات
المحافظ زي اس تي سي بي
او اسميهم بنك الحين توجهنا بنك اللي هو
موضوع الكاشباك يعرف نموذج العمل في
الشركات هذه هل اللي يتحمل الكاشباك البنك
او الشريك اللي معكم او انتم تحملوا اشباك
ولا وناصر لا هي هي هي
برامج لخدمه العميل العميل مبسوط يرجع له
جزء من اللي دفعه ساعات يرجع كامل اللي
يدفعه فتصير حراره تسويقي كويس له
طبعا هي مشاريع مشتركه
فتكلفه تكون موزعه بين الجهتين بانك جاهز
وبين البنك او الجهه المعنى مشترك كيف
تكون مجديه بالنسبه لكم اذا العميل قاعد
يصرف ويرجع لنفس المبلغ
مئه بالمئه بالمئه ريال طبعا فكيف تكون
بالنسبه لكم مقارنه بالطريقه التسويقيه
الثانيه
شرحها صعب يعني لما تاخذ اي اي نشاط
تسويقي لو خذيته القياس والواحد تكون
خسران اي شيء
اليوم تتبيع هالقهوه
خطوه جمل زين
يبي يبيع لو جاء حط حمله 100000
وجاب بكره شاف مبيعات وقال والله اليوم
بايعين اربعين الف حمله مئه الف انا
الحمله هاي ترجع لك لفتره طويله اليوم
لما اسوي كاش باك حيجي عميل جديد يجيني
لاول مره عشان يستفيد مثلا مثال بسيط فيجي
يدخل معك ويجيك اشباك فحيدخل لك مره ثانيه
عشان تستفيد المره الثانيه
90% حيستمر معك للثلاثه ورابع والخامسه
هذا مثال عميلك تكون نوع من
البيباك له انك دفعت له شيء اعطيته شي
برضو عميلك سويتوا شيء عميلك جالس يشتغل
معك ويدفع لك طول السنه
ارجع له مره حلو مبلغ المشاكل اللي تسببها
ما هي مزعجه فيها شروط تكون لا طبعا
المشاكل قليله ونسبتها قليله بس طبعا
في عالم تويتر السبعه لا غير السبع العالم
تويتر المشكله دائما الصوت العالي للشكايه
اكثر من الباقي فالمفروض ساكت انا مبسوط
ساكت وهذه على فكره وهذا عيب عندنا كثير
احنا كناس يعني
حتى حتى بينه وبين نفسه ما يمدح يعني
جربتها انا شخصيا لما واحد يقدم لي خدمه
وامدحه شوف النظره بعيونه تشوف شعوره
ترتاح نفسيا يعني انك كنت صادق وامين وكذا
يمدحون الحمد لله وكثير يعني
عملائنا حبايبنا يعني احنا جاهز مع عمله
جاهز ترى صايرين عائله بس طبيعه العروض
هذه معقده شوي بس بعض المرات يكون واحد
فهم غلط
وزعل واشتكى وبصوت يعني بعض الكلمات اللي
ما تحبها مثلا
اعلان مضلل مدري شلون
يعني خلينا احنا مع بعض
لا لا
تتجاوز بالعتاب بشكل يصل لدرجه التشكيك
بذمه اللي قدامك يعني مثلا في بعض مثلا
يصير الحمله
لحامل بطاقه فيزا مثلا
وانت جاي معك بطاقه مدى
صح ودخلت ولا جاك شباك
تقدر تقول والله ما شرحتوها بالشكل الزين
تقدر يعني
بس عموما يعني الغالبيه
99.99 مبسوطين من العرض ومستانسين من هذا
وغيره يعني والحمد لله علاقتنا برا ممتازه
مع مولانا الحمد لله ننتقل الان الى
الجانب اخر لمده يتكلم معك فيه يمكن ما
تكلمت عنه كثير قبل كذا بلقاء سابقه اللي
هي الشركات تتابع لكم والنشاطات ثانيه غير
غير جاهز اولا يعني اولا في منصه تك انا
ماني فاهم صراحه ليش قررتوا تبيعون
للمتاجر اللي في منصه بك برا جاهز ليش ما
سويتوها داخل جاهز وسارة التطبيق اللي
بتاع كله يعني في كل الاشياء هذه والسبب
اطلاقه اول شيء منصه ما مر عليهم المنصه
وليش فصلتوها عن جاهز وحتى باسم مختلف اول
شي طبعا جاهز وهذا يعني كثير ويمكن لسه
يمكن كانت فيسبوك تعاني نفس الكلام يعني
فيسبوك صار مع شركات كثيره لما غيره الاسم
صاروا ميته فبدت يعني يسوون فرق بين
فيسبوك كذا فجاهز التطبيق التوصيل الطعام
هو اسمه الشركه هو اسم التطبيق فطغى على
كل شركه جاهز مع ان احنا نتمنى انه
التطبيق التوصيل الطعام ما يتجاوز 20% من
حجم الشركه
لما بيك ليش فصلناه عن تطبيق جاهز عندنا
نظره يعني ما احنا مع شي اسمه
ولو نراجع مع بعض كم سوبر رابعه العالم
نجح قلت قليله جدا فاحنا ضدها وبنفس الوقت
احنا كشركه نعمل في هذا المجال ونعمل في
التطوير بيك ترى بدينا قبل الناس ثلاث
سنوات على الاقل وش الهدف منه
هي فكره جديده
عمل جديد مختلف كليا
عشان اشرح لك
مسار
تجاره الكترونيه من بدايتها اول ما بدات
تجاره الكترونيه واحد عنده موقع يحط
الاسماء المنتجات لما تنطلب يروح لصاحب
المنتج
مستودعاته ياخذ منه منتج بعدين نتعامل مع
شركه شحن ويشحنه ويوسخ الى شهر
وكان الناس مبسوطين عليه
بعدين صار في تطور جو الشركات الالكترونيه
قالوا
عندنا ستور في في بلد المكان الرئيسي
ونجمع فيه بضائع العالم فلما توصل الطلبات
يصير بسرعه ناخذ هالمنتجات ونشحنها فتوسخ
للاسبوع فكان
انجاز كبير جدا
انجاز تطور اخر
انه ليش ما يصير في دارك ستور
مخازن صغيره
او قبلها صار ليش ما يصير في مستودعات في
المدن الرئيسيه
الناس
وطبيعه البشر كرمالها يعني تتغير وكل ما
له النيد يزود طلبات الناس تزود
صار ابو اسبوع هذا يتاخر اسبوع يا ساتر
ولا حتى الحين
فجاء شيء اسمه الدارك ستور وشيء يسمونه
التجاره السريعه
انه والله يحطون دارك ستورز باكثر من موقع
بالمدينه فلما تطلب ياخذ من هذا يوصل لك
انه يوزع المستودعات الى داخل الاحياء
فتوصلك خلال ساعه وساعتين كان هذا برضو
قفزه كبيره في عالم تجاره الكترونيه
بعدها
طيب رجعت قالت طيب ليش اصلا احتاج ستور
ليش اصلح تاج مستودع
ليش ما اخذ من
المحلات نفسها المحل نفسه اللي هو الاستور
خلال ساعه وش فارقه على الكويت
وسماه احنا سميناه على فكره سميناه
المصطلح هذا طلع من جاهز دايركت مصطلح
طالع من جاهز من شركه جاهز والان بدا
يستخدم عالميا
فقلنا ليش مخلي هذا المستودع هل محل هو
المستودع ونخفف عليه وش فرق عن
لما يصير عندك دارك ستور حتختار مجموعه
اصناف ما تقدر تجيب كل الاصناف فيكون عندك
مجموعه اصناف يقول مثلا الف كيلو ولا شيء
انا باخذها من التاجر وبحطها عندي بمستودع
فيكون في تكلفه اضافيه هات التكلفه اضافيه
يتحملها انا كتاجر يحملها العميل هناك ما
في تكلفه اضافيه
فشيء جديد فهو بدال ما تسوي مستودع
تجمع فيه الاصناف المتوفره من اكثر المكان
مثلا تقول باخذ من المتوفر بالمحل بالمحل
بس هذا هو بخلي الاصناف اقل اذا المحل
عندك باخذ منه كامل عندك ولا كلفك التاجر
اي تكلفه اضافيه تماما
لكن موجود بالمحل ما هو يبيع للناس اللي
داخلين عليه الوقت
هذه تجربه جديده
المتاجر لسه ما هم كلهم متعودين عليها
والله اخلي المتجر هو اللي يبيع مدري شلون
فكان في معارضه بالبدايه بشكل كبير بدات
شوي شوي تزود معنا المتاجر
نتوقع انها يعني
حتضرب والبوم على قولتهم قريبا يعني يعني
مو ابعد من عشرين حتكون هي الاساس
راح تاخذ عدد كبير الناس خلاص ما يقبل انه
يتوصل له ب 24 ساعه
اتذكر اول ما بدينا حطينا شيرتات الهلال
في جاهز وهذه من ضمن افكار اللي خلانا
نروح البنك
عميل مشتكي يقول صار ساعه ونص ما وصلني
اروح اشتري من مستودع من متجر الهلال
كنت اقول الغصاب ترى ناجحين ان شاء الله
ما دامهم ساعه ونص حلو
كانوا شهر عادي الان ساعه ونص تفرق معاهم
حلوه
فالفكره بك مختلفه تماما جالسين نغير
البهافر حق الناس وهذا
وهو يتغير مع الوقت اليوم
للتسوق قبل فتره
وانت بالرياض
اذا بتطلع انت شاب ولا شاب
اهم نقطه تروح لما مول
تنبسط
اليوم انت بالرياض
مجموعه شباب المجموعات بنات عندهم ما
يروحون المطاعم يروحون فيها
بوليفارد يروحون مدري وين صارت تسوق ما هو
فسر هم بريحك
ليش تروح للمول بس هل تقدر الوقت اخدم
صاحب المول وهذه نقطه مهمه صاحب المول كان
احد اهم اعداءه تجاره الكترونيه انه يا
تشتري من اتجاه الكترونيه تشتري مني
الحين ايش اقول له حيشتري الكترونيا بس
منك
مش من مكان ثاني فانا صاحب المولو او
المتجر داخل المول ورايح العميل
التجار
ما عندي ارقام واضحه صراحه الان ولا احب
احط ارقام لكن لا اقدر اقوله انه عدى
متاجر يزيد باليوم تزيد باليوم
المبيعات جاهزه تزيد مش بالشكل المرضينا
في الامانه لكنها جالسه تزيد بشكل
نوعا ما مريح لكن عارفين انه ماشيين بالخط
الصحون ان السوق متوجه في التجاره ان
المحلات تبدا تقفل وتفتح اونلاين وتفتح زي
المطابخ السحابيه
هذا بك يخدم تماما وهو ازين
ويخدم المحلات بالعكس احنا نتوقع انه بيك
حيساعد ببقاء المحلات
انه انه عشان اذا انك موجود في في مول
معين
ومبيعاتك مثلا سبعين الف
وتحتاج ترسم مبيعات اكثر من الف عشان تقدر
تستمر وتربح ممكن يوصلك 90 الف بنفس ما
ترك بنفس كوستك حتى فيها سبعين الف في
مبيعاتك العاديه ويزيد عليها الكترونيه
ويستخدم بنفس محلك ما احتاج اي اضافات ما
احتاج اي شيء اضافي نفس محلك نفس اعاملك
نفس الكيس
هو الان مش مناديب جاهز الان صار فيه
لوجستيه ممكن نشرحها وقته صار عندنا شركه
لوجيه الان
تخدم حاليا جاهز وبك وبلو وقريبا حتخدم
الجميع جميع النموذج عمل بك نفس جاهز نسبه
ولا ايه فالنسبه تكون نسبه ثابته على كل
الطلبات اللي نسبه بس هناك تختلف عكس
المطاعم نفس النسبه هناك تختلف انك ما
تقدر مثلا تتعامل مع محل ملابس زي محل
جوالات
تلاقي هو اصلا محل جوالات
ما يوصل 4% مثلا فما كنت تقول ابغى اخذ
منك عشره بالميه ولا كذا وفي محلات لارجن
فيها
الهامش الربح كبير فتختلف
فننتقل على المنطقه السحابيه على شركه
السحابيه وسميتوها
زمن المطاعم ولا تبغون تكملون
عمرنا ما راح نصير منافسين للمطاعم ولو
فكرنا يوم من الايام من نفس المطاعم
معناته الخطا الاكبر عندنا احنا
الذراع الرئيسي لنا هو المطاعم ما قدر
نفسه بس المطعم اليوم نخدم من خلال جاهز
طيب يحتاج مساحات سحابيه
يتوسع فيها بطريقه اسهل فليش ما تقدم لهم
عن جلس اخدموا فيها مجال ثاني اليوم حتخل
قريبا في
دخلنا بالتمويل المطاعم مثلا نساهم بتمويل
المطاعم تحتاج تمويل انا اقدر اسهل لك
العمليه لن يخدمك قبل التمويل المطابخ
السحبيه الان متوفر للمطعم فرصه انه يفتح
مطبخ في منطقه جديده بشكل اكبر يعني اليوم
مطعم موجود بالرياض مثلا
يقدر يفتح ولا بحايل ولا بالدمام
بعد اسبوع
وش نموذج العمل في التكلفه يعني التكلفه
الاساسيه صفر
ما يتكلف ولا شيء نتيجه انه والله يجهز لك
المساحه ويجهز لك المكان كامل ومجهز لك
التوصيل عن طريق جاهز وغير جاهز
واخذ منك نسبه من عملك بعد تخيس منك ما
بعت ما خسرت تكلفه تجهيز المطبخ طبعا
فاناخذ نسبه انا شاركوا بنسبه نفس الشيء
بس انا ما اشيل عنه موضوع التاسيس يعني هو
يجيك بصفر ما يدفع شيء ما يدفع شيء نهائيا
نهائيا فقط يزيد النسبه يدفع
لما يبيع
فتاخذون نسبه اضافيه على ما هو اضافيه هو
لحاله جاهز لحاله حلو
اذا اذا كان باي عن طريق احد ما اسمه
معروف اساسا وما راح تجي طلبات فانت خسران
كذا
طبعا
بالشروط
يعني لازم توصل المبيعات ونسبه معينه بعد
ثلاث شهور ولا نقول له انت خسران احنا
خسرانين يعني لا نكمل مع بعض
نحاول ندعم ونحاول قويه بس اذا والله مطعم
مو قادر يبيع
ونه يستمر انتم
هل منها مسوين مطعم جاهز تحلي والمتاجر
هذا تحلي وشغله هذي هي مش مطعم هو خدمه
لهذه
جايين عندك مجموعه مطاعم حلا ومحلات حلا
تمام فطالع جهزت حلي يجمع جميع اصنافهم في
في منيو واحد يسهل على العميل ويسهل لهم
التسويقا لكن هو مش مطعم فعلي هو بس سحابي
هم موجودين داخل كوكيز وزي المحلات اللي
يجيبون حلا من الاسره المنتجه طيب
هو الان داخل المركز حقه خمسه وست محلات
حلا تمام كل واحد طالع بس مو موجود في
جاهز مثلا جهزت حلي مختار اصناف من هذولا
حاطه بالمنيو بس بس ما في شيء بالارض
الواقع ما هي منتجاتكم انتم اذا بعت خليت
منهم
جمعته وديته حلو
شركه لوجي حقت
بالتوصيل كلهم يتبعون الشركه هذه
هي شركه الخدمات اللوجستيه اللي هي توصل
المفروض
توصل شويه معقد العمليه اكثر اليوم في شيء
اسمه ساند هذا سيستم
يخدم بك وبلو وجاهز ومجهز وقريبا حيطلق
يخدم اي جهه تحتاج توزيع تمام سالت مع من
يتعامل كفيزيكال ناس تعامل مع شركه لوجي
شركه لوجي شركه دير عماله توزيع مندوبين
توزيع
الفين وشوي مندوب توزيع تحت كفاله لوجي
الجاهز ويتعامل مع حوالي 300 شركه توزيع
اخرى
يتعاملون مع ساند لتوصيل للثلاث شركات هذه
حاليا حلو فهو سيستم يدير عمليات التوزيع
والان كل طلبات جاهزه على سبيل المثال او
تطبيق جاهز كلها عن طريق لوجي لا كله عن
طريق ساند اللي هو
لكن لوجي لها موزعين
لا لا ساند هو هو نظام الكتروني يدير
عمليات التوزيع تبع جاهز تبع الشركه تبع
الشركه لهم اولاني بيصير شركه لوحده حتى
يتعامل معه شركات تحتاج توصيل وشركات
عندها قدره للتوصيل من ضمنها اليوم عندها
عندنا جاهز وبك وبلو تحتاجون توصيل حلو
وعندنا لوجي عنده قدره توصيل وفي 300 شركه
توزيع اخرى ما نملكها
عند قدره توزيع كلهم مشتبكين مع
لو باختصرها عشان بس اتاكد اني فاهم منصه
ساند تابعه للشركه الام اللي جاهز وهي
تربط ما بين الناس اللي يحتاجون خدمه زي
جاهز وبلوبك خدمه التوصيل او شركات وما
بين مقدمين خدمه التوصيل بالضبط زي لوجي
اللي هي تبعكم وشركات اخرى تقدم خدمه
التوصيل ليش شفتوا في اهميه ان شركه خاصه
فيكم للتوصيل لا لوجي طبعا لوجي او شركه
توصيل احنا احنا كتطبيق المفروض ملعقه
بالتوصيل زي ما العلاقه بالمطاعم يعني ما
راح افتح مطعم سمير مطعم جاهز ولا مطعم مش
عارف ايش المطاعم انا جاي استخدم المطاعم
واستخدم الطرف الثالث للتوزيع لكن عندنا
بالمملكه
اللست ماي لو خدمات الميل الاخير فيها نقص
كبير جدا من سنوات يمكن ثمان عشر سنوات
فلازم يتعبى هذا فاحنا جالسين الحين
مضطرين نفتح الشركه ونجيب ناس وفيها تكلفه
والعمل الماضي كلفتنا مبالغ كبيره عشان
تغطي جزء من تكاليفنا وصاير فيه حراك على
مستوى البلد انه تغذيه النقص هذا بالخدمات
الميل الاخير عايز تتغطى بشكل كامل فاحنا
اليوم مضطرين نحطها فقط عشان تخدمنا لكن
هي ما هي ما هي ما هي عملنا الرئيسي
تخدم عملنا الثاني وتجيب طبعا تستخدم ناس
على الكفالاتنا وسيارات وشكل كذا بنقص
خدمات الميل الاخير لانه عدد المناديب يا
دوب يواكب الطلب
اقل يعني طبعا هذا مو بس بتطبيقات التوصيل
وكل شيء يعني خلي اذكرك بشغله وش اكبر حدث
يصير بالعشر الاواخر من رمضان دائما
تويتر وين يصير لقطات على شركات الكورير
زحمه الناس رايحين للمستودع يبغون يجيبونه
الشكاوي ما وصل طردي ما وصل طردي ما هو
قصوره بالشركات التوصيل ترى شركات الكوريه
النقل السريع نقص بالعدد ما العدد قليل
العدد مملكه قليل نحتاج زياده يعني على
الجانب هذا مثلا
يجون بعض الناس يقول والله نبغى سعود
هالقطاع هذا والتوصيل طبعا انا معها مئه
بالمئه ودائما مع السعودي وترجع الحساب
تلاقيني دايما طالبها لكن الجزئيه هذه
اصلا فيها نقص مو انه في زايد بنغطيه في
نقص انا قوي قبل ما ادخل في السعوده خلنا
نتكلم عن المندوب الان المندوب عشان بس
الناس تقدرون تخيرون الصوره بالكامل
المندوب الان يبغى يوصل جاهز وش يسوي واحد
ما بيدخل فلوجي كمان سعودي او غير سعودي
يبغى يوصل مع جهاز ايش يسوي
في اكثر من طريق
ممكن يسجل عندنا في جاهز مباشره هذا فقط
للسعوديين اذا سعودي اسجلك عندي في جاهز
من ضمن التوصيل في جاهز وتصير مندوب تشتغل
في جاهز
او تروح دون شروط بدون شيء على طول بسيطه
معك سياره معك رخصه معك نمر بسيطه
وتشتغل على وقتك مثل ما بغيت يعني اذا
سعودي فقط سعودي تشتغل في جاهز مندوبه اخر
هل
اللوجستيه هذولا تقدر تشتغل معهم هذولا
بعضهم عماله اكفلتهم بعض الامانه مشارك
فلتهم بس
معينه يعني هل المجال هذا جالس يتطور جالس
يعني يبنى لانه هذا على فكره هذا
ارضيه لتطور كبير اليوم انت بالتطبيقات
جالس تتوسع وتشوف حجم العمل في شغلات
تتوسع بشكل
النقطه هذي الان الغير السعودي اذا ما هو
على كفاله شركات التوصيل هذا كيف يتم
تنظيم عمله هل لازم يكون يطلع رخصه عمل حر
ولا شلون ما صار له تنظيم واضح تماما
اليوم
مرحليه انه انه يسجل معها شركه التوصيل
هذه
بموافقه كفيله وبشرط تكون كفيله مش كفاله
شخصيه مش عماله منزليه لازم تصير عمل شركه
فانت عندك شركه وعندك عماله زايده ممكن
توافق تشغلهم حلو طيب عوده على سعوده
القطاع وش
الموضوع قصه سعوده احنا كل يوم تتكلم على
مناديب التوصيل او زي ما قلت لك الخدمات
الميل الاخيره اللي يوصل سواء لتطبيق سواء
لشركه نقل سواء الغيره العدد اقل من
المطلوب لا زال نحتاج نزيد العدد في مجال
كبير للشباب السعودي يشتغل بس طبعا ما
يشتغل مهنه دائمه يعني يشتغل فتره ويمشي
لازم نحتاج نجيب مناديب زياده ونطورهم
وكذا بس يصيرون اكثر
يعني
ما شفنا شيء يعني مناسب للسعودي اساسا
يشتغل فيه مناسب مرحليا يعني
بعد واحد طالب ومحتاج ماديه ترى ممتاز بس
ما تقدر تقول والله زي ما بعض يمكن
الاشخاص اللي اخترعوا يقول لك لازم سعود
الاغلبيه مستحيل
يعني حتى مع الاجانب ما انت قادر الان في
نقص مع كل الان في اجانب وفي يعني ما هم
محترفين تماما ومع ذلك كبير المفروض تزيد
باحترافيتها المندوبين سواء جانب او
سعوديين ولا زال عندك مرحله يبي لك اربع
خمس سنين عشان يصير عندك كامل الطاقم
محترف
طالب محتاج مدري ولا حتى ما تحتاج بتجرب
تشتغل لك توصلك طلبات ثلاثه اربعه خمسه
اشتري جالس تبحث عن وظيفه شهرين ثلاثه
ممكن تشتغل
وحاولنا على فكره نخلق سوق من الشباب
السعوديين
للعمل يعني كماندوبين
طلعنا قصه كانت مجنونه لو صارت ارقام
كبيره كما توقعها بعض الزملاء كان ندفع
يمكن مليارات قلنا يا مندوب اشتغل يا شاب
يا سعودي اشتغل معنا سنه واحده بمعدل خمس
طلبات باليوم نهايه السنه نعطيك هديه
سياره
بكره طبعا الحلقه حتنشر بعدين بس بكره
عندنا حفل توزيع اربعين سياره ما شاء الله
يا ربعين واحد فاز فيها بالسنه هذه
الاخيره
قبلها يمكن وزعنا خمسين سياره بس
90 واحد لكمل معنا سنه بمعدل خمس صلوات بس
اذا جاء يوم واحد
معدل المعدل
يوم بالاسبوع لكنك تجيب سته طلبات عشره
طلب يعني لو تجيب ست الطلب باليوم تحتاج
تشتغل خمسه ايام بالاسبوع بس
وضعك بالسلم سهله مره العمليه بس انه
يشتغل معنا فتره ويوصل بعدين احصل وظيفه
خلاص يبغى يكمل وغيره فهي مهنه دائمه لكن
بنفس الوقت يعني انا ضد لما يجي واحد يقول
لازم سعود القضاء كامل مستحيل
ولا يصير بس برضه لما يجي واحد يقول لك يا
اخي عيالنا ما نبي نشتغل المندوبين ليش ما
يشتغل
خليه يعمل
حلوه بس ما هي شي تقول هذا قطاع بستهدف
ولا عمليه وظيفه دائمه لكن يشتغل لفتره
تعلم ليش لا ممتازه جدا قصدي ممتازه كخيار
مؤقتا تفيدك بشغلات كثيره تعلمك
تقوي عظمك شوي تفيدك مع الدنيا تحتك
بالناس لفتره الى ان تجد وظيفتك الدائمه
انتم انتقلتوا على هالسيره بغطي بس الجانب
التشريعي في القطاع هذا انتقلته نهايه
الاتصالات الى وزاره النقل
عفوا
الاتصالات النقل ولا احنا قطاعنا اصلا
جديد تمام
فانظمت وجديده
ومتداخله مع اكثر من وزاره حيث النقل
وزاره البلديه وزاره الموارد البشريه
فنزلت تبنى الانظمه بشكل دائم بس جميع
الجهات هذه يعني متعاونه بشكل كبير الحمد
لله في تكاليف عليكم وجه الحكوميه
مباشره بس انه في تنظيم وبعد التنظيم بعض
الناس ما يحب التنظيم تنظيم مهم
للعمل في تنظيم بعد التنظيم يعني
يؤدي الى الى بعض المصاريف لكنه بشكل عام
هو الفائده في القطاع حلو شركه ثانيه برضو
في ما شاء الله في المنظومه حق جاهز اللي
هي شركه فارس من اللون الاحمر
اللون الاحمر مع استثماري لكم
طبعا خلني اقول لك وش جاهز
في جاهز الام تحت تطبيق جاهز
للطلبات وفيه لوجي
الشركه اللوجستيه وفي بك تكلمنا عنها قبل
شوي شركه تطبيق يعني غالبا يميل للنسائي
اكثر لكنه هو ما نفوت مش اكل تطبيق في بلو
وتطبيق شبابي رياضي طبعا في مفهوم خاطئ
انه متجر هلال وليس متجر الهلال
متاجر عامه وشبابيه لكن هو تطبيق رياضي
شبابي لدي حصريه في منتجات الهلال
لكن هو مش متجر الى وفي طبعا جاهز
بالبحرين وجاهز بالكويت وان شاء الله
قريبا باكثر من دوله خليجيه وفيه مرن مرن
بيوس
نقاط كشير
وكثير من الشغلات اللي فهمتك على خفيف هذا
ايه
وفي
اللون الاحمر او الرج هذه شركه
استثماريه تستثمر مجالين
الان مستثمره بمجموعه من الشركات الصغيره
والمتوسطه باستثمارات بسيطه يعني توزيع
استثمارات فقط وتستثمر ببعض الشركات اللي
نبغى
يعني
تكامل معها لبناء
اليوم مثلا
مشتركه في
اللون الاحمر مثلا هذاك استثمار بشكل كامل
لكن مثلا مستثمر بشركتين لوجستيه
قريبا يعني وحده خليجيه وواحده سعوديه
منها
بمنظوماتنا نحتاج غير لوجي نحتاج شركات
ثانيه مشتركه مثلا اليوم مستثمره بشركه
حتى تزود المطاعم مبيعات الجمله بطريقه
الكترونيه فحتكمل الصوره بشكل كامل فهي
اللون الاحمر خطه الرئيسي اما استثمار بحث
استثمار للنمو فقط او استثمارات تفيد في
الصوره الكامله لشركه جاهز لانه شركه جاهز
نشوفها بلاد فورم كبير في اكثر من خدمه
متكامله مع بعض
فواحد زائد واحد يساوي اربعه استثماراتكم
في مثل نعناع وهلا هي تصب في مصلحه جاهز
من ناحيه اكمال المنظومه او انها يعني
بعضها كده وبعضها كذا يعني مثلا استثمارنا
في نعناع مثلا هو الجزء الرئيسي استثمار
يعني بحث استثمار للاستثمار لكن برضو في
علاقات بيننا وبين نعناع كبيره نعناع داخل
تطبيق جاهز لاحظته فهذا من باب التعاون
بين الشركات لكنه استثمارنا صغير يعني ما
هو ما ياثر على قرارهم انهم يكون معنا ولا
ما يكون معنا هذاك كله علاقه خاصه
حلواتكم عليها اللي هو نظام نقاط البيع
لانه
كامل الخدمات المطعم
احنا نبغى نكمل للتجامل الصوره للتجاره
الالكترونيه ولا الديجيتال بشكل عام
فجلسين نتوسع بمجال كبير بالدجز
هذه جزء منه مهم مهم انكم فيه نفس الوقت
حنستثمر بعقول يعني لما نستثمر بمرن ويكون
معنا مؤسسين مرن موجودين معنا الان
جالسين نزيد عقول على الشركه
في مجال عالمي يمكن ما هو منتشر عندنا
كثير بالسعوديه هنا لكنه عالميا معروف انه
تستحوذ لله غير انه للشركه يعني سعود
لتوظيف الفريق لتوظيف الفريق فانت تيجي
تقول والله في فريق ممتاز يا اجر روح حاول
اغريهم اجيبهم كموظفين عندي على واحد واحد
اللقطهم ياخذ هذولا كلهم
فهذه مفيده فزي ما رن فيها الثنتين فيها
تكمل المنظومه حقتنا وفيها نفس الوقت جبت
فريق متمكن متجانس مره واحده صار من ضمن
مجموعه هل هذا يعني انه الخدمات اللي تقدم
للتجار داخل المحلات في مختلف انواعها هي
قد تكون هدف استحواذ لكم مستقبلا
مو شرط يعني انا ما ابغى اصير كل شيء لازم
اشتغل فيه بس اللي يمثل الصوره الكامله
حقتنا مستقبلا نمشي فيها عندنا هدف
وتوجه زي ما قلت لك قبل شوي لما اتكلم على
الناشونال هيروز هذا هدف حكومي في هدف
حكومي كان لانشاء لتكوين شركات ملياريه
ويمكن سمعت انه كثير وكنا واحنا نقول احنا
نبغى نمشي مع هدف حكومي ونامل نصير واحد
من الشركات المليريه والحمد لله صرنا
اليوم في هدف حكومي برضو ضمن الاقتصاد
المتكامل بالمملكه انه انشاء شركات
ابطال
حكم وطنيه تنتقل الى خارج المملكه ففي
شركات كانت قويه وجاهزه انك تصير هان
ناشيونال هيروز وفي شركات يعني
جاهز وحده منها احنا ماشيين مع الهدف اللي
يتوافق مع الهدف الحكومي نتمنى جزء منه
حيكون نكسب احنا كشركه بشكل كبير وبنفس
الوقت نتوافق مع هالرؤيه اللي احنا فيها
احنا ترى وهذه برضو للتجار احنا اليوم
للشركات احنا ماشيين ضمن رؤيه عظيمه
اسمه سيدي الامير محمد بن سلمان واحنا
قطعنا يمكن مشوار فيها في في وصول لعشرين
ثلاثين هالرؤيه هاي ترى ما هي شغله حكوميه
فقط الرؤيه هذه تشمل
جهات حكوميه شركات خاصه افراد حتى حنا
كافراد حتى جزء من هالرؤيه فاليوم انت
كشركه لما تحاول
يعني
تكيف نفسك
للتوافق محل رؤيه تكون حصلت الحسنين نجحت
بشكل اسرع وبنفس الوقت ساهمت ولو بشكل
بسيط بنجاح البلد اللي انت فيه جميل رؤيته
من جانب الاستماره استحواذ
مهم اللي هو الاستحواذ على
يبدو انه شكلا على الاقل من برا زي جاهز
وايش اللي خلاكم تهتمون في جهتين الاولى
طبعا انت كشركه لازم تنمو
تنمو بشكل سريع ومطلوب منك انك تنمو
ايرادات وعملاء وكل شيء والنمو شيء منه
يسمونه طبيعي النمو الثاني انك تستحوذ هذا
هذا يعني موجود على مستوى العالم يعني
فهذه واحده منها انه والله انه بجيب شركات
مشابهه ابى اخذها خذيت عملائها خذيت
مبيعاتها نمت بشكل يعني مو شكل الطبيعي
الارجانيك لا نمت بشكل اسرع اللي هو عن
طريق الاستحواذ غير ايش
احب اقول لك اثنين فيها كفاءات برضو مميزه
منها ثلاثه اذا شفت ترى حاله خاصه من
التطبيقات
كل التطبيقات بجهه الشيبس لوحدها
اكتشفت جالسين يشتغلون النيش الخدمات
مميزه
لطبقه اعلى طبقه شوي خاصه لو انهم بعدين
بداوا ينزلون تحت عشان يتوسعون يكبرون
احنا نبغى بهالطبقه
هذه المميزه خل نقول في اي بي سيرفس هذه
اللي بداوا فيها يمكن الحين نزلوا شوي
حتفيدنا لما نخليها شركه تشتغل بالمجال
هذا احنا مركزين في جهاز والباقي وفي
منافس كان نحاول يستحوذ عليهم قبلكم
شوي بالحوار قلت احد الشركات اللي داخل
السعوديه قلت منافسنا هي ما هي منافسنا
حنا اللي نافسنا حقيقيا بالمنطقه هي شركه
ديليفرو هيرو الشركه الالمانيه احنا
نتنافس احنا وياها طبعا شركه عالميه
المانيه موجوده باكثر مكان بالعالم بس ليش
دليفري هيرو لا هي دي نفسنا وليس
المالكه هذه موجوده باكثر منطقه بالعالم
موجوده عندنا بالسعوديه موجوده بدور
الخليج
يعني شركه ما هي سهله قويه استطاعه باغلب
دول الخليج انها تصير شبه حصري طلعت جميع
المنافسين تمسك السوق
بالسعوديه استحوذت طبعا على هنقرستيشن
اصلها سعودي شركه السعوديه استحوذت عليها
وحاول تسوي نفس الشيء
وقفنا لها شوي بالحلق الحمد لله ما قدرت
تطلعنا نافسناها قوينا اليوم طلعنا من
السعوديه رحنا لها بالبحرين بالكويت فهي
منافسنا
وقفتهم انه انت شركه اجنبيه قاعد تحاول
تكوش على السوق يعني هم يحاولون كذا بس
طبعا
شروطهم بس يعني استغرب يوم كانت
وقت يعني
دولات الاستحواذ من هيرو على هذا الشيبس
حيث مناسب طبعا دائما يسوون الهمر حقهم
يشوفون جميع الاطراف كذا يحاولون يدرسون
الموضوع فمن ضمنها
تواصلوا
كانوا يسالون عملياتنا فاجئناهم بالعكس يا
اخي كملوا الصفقه
حنا نرى ان تكمل الصفقه كنا وقتنا نقول
يعني
والله اذا شفت شباب سعوديين مجتهدين
فقلت ما بنا خير اذا ضرتنا هالصفقه احنا
اقوىنا طبعا التوجيهات مباشره من رئيس
مجلس الاداره اتذكر قال لي لا تلدهم خلهم
يمشون وابدا الله يوفقك ان شاء الله
هالشباب
عبد الرحمن المرشد والاخواني شيبس واحنا
والله اذا ضعاف لدرجه انه والله
ما تمت لاسبابنا ما اعرفها
اليوم ترى الى اللحظه هذه على فكره ما
اكتملت يعني مددتوها الفتره لسه ما خذينا
موافقه من حيث
ننتظر الموافقه لسه في احتمال انه
احتمالات وارده بسبب هيئه المنافسه او
بسبب شيء بينكم وبين
مجلس الموافق
لا يكون في خلافات ولا يكون فيه مشكله لا
يكون لا لا ما في ان شاء الله طبعا في
تعرف الاستحواذ فيه لازم يكمل في شغلات
كثيره وموافقات
موافقه المنافسه موافقه هيئه سوق المال لم
فيها من حساسهم ما يكن لها كاش فلازم اضغط
هاي السوق المال وفيديو للجنس كلها ماشيه
بالمجال لكن الان احنا ما وصلتنا يعني
موافقه حلو واكماله موضوع الشراكات وكمان
كل الخدمات يقدمون للتجار عندكم ايضا
شراكه مع الرائد للتمويل لتمويل التجاري
اللي ذكرته قبل شوي صح في اكثر من شركه
للتمويل طبعا احنا شركاتنا كثيره جدا بعد
جهات حكوميه وجهات خاصه بالتمويل احنا
عندنا شراكه مع بنك منشات لتمويل المطاعم
والمتاج يتعاملوا معنا عندنا شراكه مع فرص
برضو تمويل والان وعندنا مع الامثل
واليوم وقعنا مع الرائد
تمويل وتستقطعون ومستحقاته صح نظما
مستحقاته وبخره طبعا ما نستقطع رسميا يعني
ما نستقطع من من
مبالغ عشان نسدد الجهه لكن زي اللي نضمن
بطريقه اخرى او
نعطي ضمانات معينه للممول انه هذا والله
ماشي شغال فالمطعم اللي ياخذ تمويل من
خلالكم لا بد يكون في حركه معينه على
حسابه هي يعني على الاقل يصير يعني يتوافق
مع قيمه مع حجم عمله حلو وايضا في ذيب
لتاجير السيارات
طبعا عقد كبير اللي هو بمعنى بلوجي
ذيب معهم مع لوجي شركه لوجي اللي هي شركه
التوصيل اليوم ترى عنده شركه توصيل تستغرب
مع انه الرئيسي لكن شركه التوصيل تملكها
جاهز تعتبر واحده من اكبر شركات التوصيل
في العالم العربي ما شاء الله عدد السطور
ونزلين يكبر
شلون هم انهم يروحون يستخدمون تطبيقات
منافسين
هذول الجزء الثاني اللي كلنا نبغى نتخلص
منه اليوم بالتوصيل حتلاقي جزء منظم
حتلاقي السعوديين
وتلاقي جزء منظم وجزء غير منظم الغير منظم
هذا العميل استامن
ومضمونا احنا شركات نستامنه الجهات
الحكوميه تستامنه هذا جالسين كلنا احنا
كتطبيقات مع الجهات الحكوميه
نقلصه وان شاء الله باقرب وقت ينتهي هذول
اللي ماسك ذا التطبيقات اللي تلاقيه راكب
له دباب مدري شلون شنطه ورا بلاستيك هذول
كلهم معقول غير نظاميين هو مقيم بالبلد
صحيح وموافق على عمله ورقمه مسجل في في
هيئه النقل وكل شيء لكنه ما هو مندوب
توصيل محترف
كان النقاش هل
نعمل نسير جميع طاقم التوصيل محترفين فورا
كان هذا توجه بعض الجهات الحكوميه بس انه
مع اجتماعاتنا حكوميه كان انه لو حاولنا
نخليهم جميعها محترفين فورا حنخفس بالسوق
يمكن ثمانين بالمئه وتاثر المطاعم
قبل شوي ذيب وقلت لك معها في يوردون الاكل
في اللي يوردون الدعايات في شركات الدعايه
في في في سلسله طويله يعني صناعه كبيره
فصار التوافق اننا خلنا نتحول الى عمل
محترف خلال ثلاثي اربع سنوات وماشيين
بهالخط حلو اليوم مثلا حتلاقي عند العدد
السعوديين لا باس فيه عندنا لوجي حول 2200
مندوب تبع كفالتنا عندنا حوالي ثلاث اربع
شركات السعوديين كم عددهم السعوديين
يصلحون عشره الاف بس انتاجيتهم شوي يعني
ما نفس الغير السعودي طبعا ظروفه وكذا
فانتجتهم 5000
فعندنا شركتين استثمرنا فيهم شغلهم منظم
بعد ومرتب واحد اسمه برق يمكن تسمع فيها
واحنا نسمع بارسل هذه شركه خليجيه وعندنا
حوالي عشر الى 12 شركه لوجستيه منظمه
وجالسين يعني نتساعد معها منهم اكثر
تنظيما بعد اليوم اللي يسمعوا يبغى الشركه
لوجستيه محترفه مفتحين انتم تستثمرون جدا
لا ما نستثمر الاستثمار مو شرط يعني على
حسب لا امور بس تقول لي انصح انك تكون
شركه لوجستيه اقول لك انصح بقوه لكن يبغى
لك طوله نفس شوي انه خلال هالسنتين لما
يروحون غير المحترفين شوي شوي
حيبقى سوق منظم وفي قطاع كبير وفي مجال
كبير للنمو
ومجال مثمر مفيد صح كيف احنا تكلمنا يمكن
عن المنافس واحد اليوم بس كيف مشهد
المنافسه بشكل
ابرز انتم هنقرستيشن مرسول اللي دايما
بالقمه نسمع نسمع عنهم دائما بس في ايضا
عدد اقل من العملاء في مستر مندوب مسوي
شوي زحمه الفتره الاخيره ويحاول يلعب على
جانب
النسبه سواء حقت المناديب او حق المطاعم
حسب ما اذكر على الاقل فكيف تشوفون مشهد
منافسه كبير السوق كبير ويسال كثير
طبعا ذكرت مجموعه من الاسامي اكثر ذكرتهم
شركات يعني مميزه وكويسه لو انا من خارج
القطاع ممكن استثمر فيها مباشره وبعضهم لا
يعني
[موسيقى]
نحتاج
عمل صحيح يعني انك انك تعمل بشكل صحيح
وليس تدعي انك انك تعمل فكثير من الشركات
اللي ذكرتها بالعكس شركات سعوديه مميزه
واتوقع على نمو وتكبر
والمجال كبير لا زال يعني لا زال حتى في
مجال انك تدخل شركات جديده على هالسوق سوق
كبير مره ترى مو مو صغير جميل الطرح كيف
كانت
افضل
واجمل
واسوا واصعب قرار ما الحين بعد ما مر
الوقت هذا كله ما تحس انه كان المفروض
تاجل كان مثلا ممكن تشوفون شيء في تغيرون
شي في التقييم في
يعني في اي اي
اصعب اجمل لانك
تخارج بطريقه جديده على شركات
التقنيه ما كانت موجوده يعني قبل هل هل
قبل هالطرح حق جاهز اي شركه تقنيه تبني
تشتغل تنتظر انه يجيها شركه دوليه تشتريها
هذا عملها تخرج على المستوى الشخصي لكم
ممتاز ابغى اقولك هنا بالجزئيه فصار في
تخارج كويس
اجمل اصبحت شركه ضخمه اصبحت شركه كبيره
اصبحت شركه لها تقييمها لها تقدير لها
احترام هذا ما اصعب لانه قبل كان القرار
بيد ثلاثه اربعه خمسه اشخاص ملاك اسهل
يعني الحركه اسرعكم شوي يعني نوعا ما في
قوانين في كذا في شغلات شوي صعبه
اسوا انك انك قبل مهما تشتغل تحس انك
والله انا اشتغل وبحلالي
وباقي الشركه قريبين مني فرحنا يمين على
يسار ما يصير ها الهم عليك اليوم ممكن في
واحد مالك بجنوب افريقيا
ويملك عندك فانت تبغى شايل هم انه نكون
راضي عليك او على الاقل انك انت مؤدي
الامانه له لانه مستامنك على الشغل وهو
بجني بامريكا ولا بريطانيا ولا بالسعوديه
بمكاتره على فكره ملاك جاهز
الغير سعوديين الجهات غير سعوديين
جاهز قد تكون رقم اثنين او ثلاثه بعدد
المستثمرين الاجانب في شركه السعوديه رقم
واحد ارامكو
بتقييم مبالغ فيه اول شيء يعني ترى مو
جاهز تقييم هذا واحد
لما نقول تقييم ترى ما يعني ما انت بتطرح
بالسوق تجي تقول انا والله سعري
الف السهم
التقييم يجي عن طريق بيوت خبره وبنوك
ومستثمرين امر قيمون ويطرح قيمه السهم
اثنين النزول مسلم بالمئه
نزل شي بسيط ويمكن النزول الاكبر اللي
قريبين من السوق يعرفونه انه والله تركيبه
جاهز كان في مجموعه مستثمرين صندوق استثمر
في جاهز قبل الطرح
هالصندوق في عدد كبير لا باس فيه كميه شخص
ما ادري كم عدده على الحدود زين هذولا
استثمروا ب 500 الف لمليون
ومبالغهم
تضاعفت 20 مره 25 مره بعد الطرح
فانت تخيل انك مساهم 500 الف صار عندك
عشرين مليون مثلا
جيتك فرصه انك تبيع فتخرجوا تخارجوا ولو
يطلع بنص القيمه هو كسبان مكسب كبير
فطلعوا عدد كبير منها
لكن الرقم اعطيك قصه
يمكن من النوادر بالشركات تلاقي مؤسسين
يشترون بعد الطرح انا شخصيا مشتري بعد
الطرح
ليش يوم نزل السهم شفتوا
حلو انا مشتري بعد الطرح بعد النزول
برضه عندك
الفكره انه انه
لسه جاهز اكبر بكثير من كذا بس سعرها ينزل
يطلع طبعا عاد على قولتك بتويتر وكذا في
بعض عاد اللي يعني ممتعين
جاهز
وثلاثين شلون اغلى من ارامكم
يعني بس هو على الاداء انه في ناس يقولون
اوه شكلها كان مبالغ فيه ليش انحاش
والمستثمرين تعرف الاستير سالفه بس في
تويتر طبعا هو السبب الرئيسي انا اعتقد زي
ما قلت لك انه مجموعه مستثمرين اللي دخلوا
كصندوق
واكسبهم مبالغ كبيره وطلعوا اصلا يوم
نزولها يوم توزيع الصندوق موزع الاسهم على
على ملاك الصندوق بس برضه في ناس يستشهدون
ما بقول اجيبها من السالفه انه صار في
انخفاض كبير ايضا في ارباح في نهايه السنه
الماضيه كان جزء منه او الاساسي ذكرتوه
انه كان الارتفاع اسعار
التوصيله التوصيل والجهات الحكوميه هذا ما
اذكر الصيغه
بعطيك قصه
اجاوبني
اثنين اخوان
جابوهم اعطاهم بيتين شعبيه حلو ومئه الف
كل واحد قال له خذ 100000 خذ بيت
واحد
اجر البيت بعشره الاف
الثاني هد البيت
وخذ قرض من البنك مليون وبناله عماره
نهايه السنه
جو يشوفون ارباحهم الاول اللي اجر قال
رابع عشره الاف ما شاء الله عنده ارباح
ثاني خسران
دفع حق البنك يعني اللي يدفعه خلال
خسران 100 الف
السنه الثانيه
راعي البيت الشعبي اجر عشره الاف ثانيه
ربحان عشره الاف صار عندي 120 الف الحين
هذاك خسران 100,000 ثانيه نزل يبني
السنه الثالثه
هذا اجر بعشره الاف
ولا خلاص
اكتملت العماره واجرها
العام الماضي اللي يتكلمون على خساره
لما تشوف جاهز لحالها
في هذه الحاله ارباح العام الماضيه اعلى
من قبله
لكن اربع هذي خذتها وصرفت في
بك في بلوك وفي جهاز البحرين وفي جاهز
الكويت وفي لوجي
حلو حلو فصرفت كل المبالغ
رب ربحيتي اقل وصرفت على فكره شركات جاهزه
ما تعتبر مصروف فما تبين بالربح لكن احنا
ننشئ اهم الصفر
فيبين انه خسرانه لكن صحيح تستثمر
ات مو خسرانه
بتفسير وخسرانه بغض النظر عن ارتفاع في
تكاليف التوصيل المقارنه بالسابق
كيف توصيل تنقص ما هي السبب ما صار في
تكاليف الرئيسيه كانت في تاسيس لوجي
لوجي الشركه اللوجيه كلفت طبعا في جزء
منها اللي هو غير متكرر كيف هي جزء يعني
طبعا
يعني صرفنا بالوجه يمكن اكثر من اللازم
لسبب انه جبنا سواقين عشان نشغلهم خلينا
وقت اطول عشان تطلع رخصه يبغى لك ثلاث
شهور اربع شهور بعض الامور اللوجستيه
تاسيسها وشوي صعبه
فصرفنا اكثر من اللازم فيها لكن بشكل عام
احنا طلعنا من السنه واحنا عندنا لوجي
وعندنا بيك عندنا بلو عندنا جاهز بالكويت
وجاهز بالبحرين فجارس
تتوسع لكن بشكل عام تقول لي والله جاهزه
اليوم وجاهز قبل سنتين جاهز اليوم اكبر
حلو هنا يمكن يقودنا الى المحور الاخير
نتكلم فيه اللي هو وين رايحين جاهز وين
تشوفون نفسكم مثلا
السنه الجايه السنه بعدها الى خمس سنوات
قدام مش الاشياء اللي بتستثمرون فيها
بس وين وين متوجه
في في جاهز
كمبدا لكن احنا نستثمر بالتطبيقات بشكل
كامل يعني خليني اقول لك جهتين جاهز
المشهور التطبيق
نبغاه يكبر يتطور وتجود خدمات عليه
مثلا خدمات
اشتري لانود فلاح لاحقا
تحملونها على التاجر ولا
تتوزع بطريقه عادله
اكثر من خدمه حتدخل فيه قريبه فهو المفروض
انه يكبر اثنين عندنا هدف رئيسي انه جاهز
هالتطبيق المدلع اللي اللي هو الهيرو حقنا
انه ما يمثل اكثر من 20% من جاهز هذا هدف
رئيسي عندنا اثنين شلون نتوسع جغرافيا
يعني افقيا راسيا عقلاتهم جغرافيا رحل
الخليج وحنروح ان شاء الله الدول اكثر
وراسيا نبي نشتغل باكثر من مجال واكثر من
من فيرتكل يعني زي ما قلنا بدينا
بالتطبيقين لكن في خدمات ثانيه خدمات
خدمات لوجستيه
نطور فيها بعد لكن لما اعطيك شكل عام اننا
يعني هدفنا انه ما يصير جاهز اكثر من
عشرين جاهز التطبيق اكثر من عشرين بالمئه
من جاهز الشركه حلو وما تصور في اشياء
غير منطقيه اللي هو التوصيل من خلال
الدرونز مثلا
مجرد فكره يعني يعني خلك اكون واقعي جدا
فيها
واحد يقول لك التوصيل خلال درونزي بصير
قريبا هذا حاله
واحد يقول لك لا يا رجال اترك الدرونز لا
تقرب لها وهذه بعدين هذا انسان غير واقعي
اليوم احنا عندنا
بحوث
بالتنسيق مع جامعه
الملك عبد الله في في رابغ شغالين على
بحوث
لعمليات الدرونز او حتى السيارات الصغيره
التي تتحرك لوحدها فجلسين يعني نشتغل معهم
مستعدين للمستقبل جالسين نبغى أصيد جزء من
هالمستقبل ندري انه مو بكره
بس يمكن يتسارع قريبا فاننا لو نجي ندعي
انه نشتغل وبكره نكون
حالمين لو نجلس الناس حتسبقنا
فجالسين نشتغل فيها زائد في شركه برضو
امريكيه عندنا احنا وياهم تواصل وعندنا
يعني
نوع من الدراسات بهذه وحيكون حتجينا برضو
بعض الاجهزه بعض الادوات اللي احنا
نستخدمها بالتجارب هنا بالمملكه
بخصوصا بعض الاماكن المغلقه زي زي مثلا
مدينه الرائده
مكان مغلق ممكن يصير فيه فبرضه شغالين
فيها الله يعطيك العافيه يا عبد الله ابو
عبد الله طولنا معك اليوم لكن ما شاء الله
قاعدين ننبش نعرف جاهز فيه وش عندها
بالضبط اللي هي الشركه الام صراحه انبهرت
في المعلومات اللي عرفتها من كثر الاشاره
يسوونها حتى ما في مجال نناقشكم مستقبلا
شكلكم وصلتوا ما شاء الله لا استثمار لا
استحوذات لا تفاصيل كثيره اعتقد بيستفيد
منها كثير الناس اللي عاملين في السوق
سواء تجار سواء رواد عمان سواء كان
مستثمرين فشكرا لك على وقتك
نورتنا اليوم واثريت الله يسلمك ويخليك
بالعكس سعيد ان يكون معك وتعرف زي ما قلت
لك بديت لقائنا يعني تعرف رايي الشخصي بك
ثقتي فيك وعشان كذا انبسطت وجيت معكم يمكن
اختم شغله واحده يعني تجاهز
تجربه ترى يعني انا اعتقد ان تجربه ناجحه
الحمد لله وتجربه يعني مثال
وانا الصراحه فخور اني جزء منها واعتقد
النجاح مو لمجموعه افراد نجاح لشباب
سعوديين كان عندهم طموح كان عندهم
ايمان بقدراتهم وايمان
بقدرات هالبلد اللي احنا فيه فالحمد لله
اليوم انا فاخر لما نجلس مع شركات اوروبيه
ولا امريكيه ونتكلم معهم ولا صينيه ونتكلم
معهم لما تسمع الثناء اللي يجينا منهم على
جاهز تجربه جاهز والله يعني رقبت الواحد
طول بس مو لاني انا بجاه سعودي
قدرنا الحمد لله كشباب سعوديين مكسر حواجز
كثيره
تخلينا فعلا نعيش بالفخر شغله ثانيه اننا
برضو محظوظين يعني اليوم
ولا هي والله مجامله ولا هو كلام للتسويق
لكن فعلا اليوم حنا كشباب سعودي بهالبلد
المطاط محفوظين يعني الله سبحانه وتعالى
ثم دعم الكثير من ضمنهم كثير من جهه
الحكوميه ما وصلنا وصلنا له يعني يقول
ما لا يشكر الناس لا يشكر الله يعني
وزاره الاتصالات هيئه الاتصالات وزاره
النقل هيئه النقل وزاره المواد البشريه
وزاره البلديه
وزاره الصحه كثير من الجهات ساهمت
في يعني دعمنا
خلاط الناصر اللي وصلناه الحمد لله وضوح
الرؤيه نفسها اصلا يوريك وين رايح الدوله
وين تقدر تستثمر فيها بالضبط
الامور ماشيه مفتوحه لك
امشحه قدام خلك جزء من الرؤيه تواصل هناك
حتساهم وحتستفيد اكثر وهذه على مستوى
الافراد على مستوى شركات على مستوى كل شيء
الله يعطيك العافيه ابو عبد الله
شكرا لكم وشكرا لعبد الملك ال سعيد في
انتاج المحتوى في التحرير مرمط بيبان في
اداره التصوير ياسر بن غانم في الاضاءه
عبد المجيد عمر الهندسه الصوتيه عبد
العزيز المزي في الاخراج الابداعي وهاب
موسى الخراج الفني مجد الملي ومساعده وسيم
معين وفي الانتاج التنفيذي غيداء التميمي
هذا
منتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر والتوزيع
[موسيقى]